Matt Walsh has dropped a Twitter thread
outlining how Fox News is forcing pride
and doctrination on their employees and
oh boy it is particularly graphic we got
that story around the same time
interestingly that uh Fox was
reprimanding an employee who called Joe
Biden a wannabe dictator and then 24
hours later this individual resigned
we're learning a lot about this from
Tucker Carlson but I have to wonder if
there is something going on
there may be an overlap in these stories
what I can say is we here at timcast do
have some privied information as it
pertains to this story and what's going
on at Fox News and so uh we're going to
be able to talk quite a bit about it in
the context of what Matt Walsh has
released as well as what we know and how
we know it so I think this should be
particularly interesting we'll talk
about that plus Joe Biden snapping at
reporters once again because he's being
accused of being the big guy how come
you're being uh called the big guy by
these Executives what a stupid question
he's not particularly happy about that
we'll talk about that and then of course
last night in the members only section
uh become a member at timcast.com go to
timcast.com click join us go to the mem
uh sign up for the Discord join our
members only show we'll have one up
tonight at 10 pm but the reason I bring
this up writing the intro is someone
informed us that Yingling had sponsored
an all ages drag show
and we looked into it it's true uh a
little more complicated but Yingling
sponsors a venue that is hosting an all
ages drag show and this is a lot of
people disappointed but they deleted
their tweet promoting the event so we're
gonna break this story down and into
what's exactly going on with Yingling
because we're big fans of Yingling and
it'd be we'd be sad to hear I mean
apparently the Yuengling guys are uh big
big Trump supporters too so I wonder
what this is all about some are saying
they've only sponsored the venue they
don't have anything to do with the
individual events but then they're still
providing some kind of funding that
allows these events to happen so we'll
get into that but before we do my
friends head over to castbrew.com You
Gotta Buy cast Brew Coffee that's right
our coffee company we're sponsoring
ourselves if you like coffee and you
want really good coffee everyone keeps
telling us the rise with Roberto Jr
breakfast blend is the best and I gotta
agree it's it's amazing it's a light
roast we also have a dark roast
Appalachian nights go to castbrew.com if
you would like to buy coffee from us if
you need coffee you should buy it from
us support our work and help fight the
commies by supporting companies that
don't hate you and then as I mentioned
go to timcast.com become a member by
clicking join us but also if you go to
timcast.com there is now a mobile app
link you can click that and we'll bring
you to the mobile app section where you
can download for Android the mobile app
the Apple app is not yet available only
because we're waiting for Apple approval
and the apps are not yet on their
respective app stores because we've been
waiting months for approval from the
mobile platform services but in the
meantime we've uploaded the installation
file directed to the website so those
that are on Android can directly install
the app
and uh watch the show through there so
uh definitely check out the mobile app
at timcast.com smash the like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends joining us tonight to
talk about this and so much more welcome
back Dale Turner it's great to be here
thank you it's I've been a while Daniel
Turner powerthefuture.com your favorite
fossil fuel Advocate and sheep farmer so
great to be back what's going on with
these record low temperatures Daniel
have you noticed that it's all my fault
it's all climate change it's all I I am
personally responsible for all of this
for the record low temperatures all of
it high low storms hurricanes lack
thereof it's all my fault no matter what
happens to the weather it's you yeah it
is it is I personally control it the
fossil fuel industry is responsible
could you cut that out I don't know how
much you got he controlled the weather
Sheamus got like thirty dollars so just
real quick though um we've actually had
record low temperatures I keep getting
warnings it was chilly today yeah I'm I
have a on my computer there's like a a
severe weather alert that I've been
getting for the past couple weeks saying
record low temperatures because it's
it's dropping down at night to the 40s
in the in like the high 40s and that
means like vegetation is going to start
suffering so uh I guess that's actually
climate change too like no matter what
happens no matter what happens yeah and
and there are parts of the of the the
world Hudson Bay is going through
extreme highs Southern California is
going through extreme highs we're going
through extreme lows and that's this is
Mother Nature and there's nothing you
can do to stop it right on well we uh
thanks for hanging out Daniel we got
shame thank you uh I'm Sheamus I make
cartoons I have YouTube channel called
Freedom Tunes we just released a cartoon
today about Donald Trump being on trial
for something Joe Biden actually did uh
if you guys want to check that out I
think you'll enjoy the audience really
seems to be liking it and we had a great
time working on it
cool and I'm Hannah Claire brimlow I'm a
writer for timcast.com I'm happy to be
here not Ian no I'm not Ian 100 this is
not Ian today he's a one of a kind we
can't really replace him but I am here
to fill the seat Ian has phasing which
means yes they shed his skin there's a
period where he phases out of existence
into and out of if you play Magic the
Gathering you know that reference Oh I
thought you're gonna say like sheds like
a snake and he has to nope nope he
phases it out of reality he's in a big
cocoon right now he molts like a crab
you know he molts like a crab
like uh uh Zoidberg that's right well I
look forward to seeing his new
exoskeleton uh I'm surge.com I'm ready
to start when you guys are here's the
story from the postmodial breaking Fox
News promotes glory holes child
sterilization to employees leaked
documents reveal Matt Walsh revealed the
fox Corporation parent company of Fox
News is encouraging employees to
celebrate pride month and all things
lgbtqia plus come on I at a certain
point I can't keep reading all these
letters I mean that seriously maybe just
we say like the pride Community or
something by giving money to groups that
encourage sex changes for minors reading
books by trans activists including books
about children changing changing gender
gay erotica and sharing children's books
about gender transition with their with
their children and to attend activist
Pride events so this is the thread from
Matt Walsh she says we've obtained
internal documents from Fox News
employees foxcorp is celebrating Pride
by encouraging employees to read about
glory holes supporting a group that
gives sterilizing hormones to homeless
Youth and deployed woke AI to monitor
everyone
there's a big long thread but uh I will
just say this uh first and foremost I
can confirm this now I can't confirm
each and every uh intricate detail what
I can confirm is I have I have spoken
with Fox employees who have told me
exactly this
and I do believe personally that what
was going on at Fox was well known in
the media space among anyone who is
considered to be libertarian
conservative in this in this space not
every single libertarian but mostly the
anti-woke anti-leftist or whatever if
there's a conservative personality I
think most of them knew this was going
on at Fox
and I think people just didn't want to
call out Fox because then they would not
be invited onto Fox to speak they
wouldn't get the air time now in the
past couple of months there have been
some goings on where we became
privileges information and the main
reason we have not really brought
anything up as one we didn't get leaked
documents or anything like that we just
had testimony from employees and we were
asked to wait as a story was being
prepared and sure enough bang the story
just came out Matt Walsh dropping the
documents this is actually uh
unsurprising
but I think what uh what y'all need to
realize is that Fox News is
what can I call it a hoax well this is
I've said this before right CNN tells
you what you're supposed to believe and
then Fox tells you what you're allowed
to believe if you're someone who
genuinely can't stomach the nonsense
that they're pushing over at CNN you can
go over to Fox and they'll tell you
what's within the confines of socially
acceptable conservatism the whole goal
I'm not saying it's an Express or
intentional goal of the people at the
Fox network but it just happens to work
out this way that they give you a much
more brand safe version of the ideology
in a kind of Kohl's people this is part
of why Tucker Carlson was so dangerous
to their status quo because he was
Shifting the Paradigm in an
anti-establishment and a direction that
was further to the right and so he was
he was saying things that previously
conservatives uh would have been
considered nut jobs for saying because
he was actually offering up a narrative
counter to what the establishment was
saying without simply making the
argument that I don't like what CNN
saying um I don't like what Joe Biden is
doing but without actually promoting a
substantive counter ideology if that
makes sense
and so we had a whole conversation about
this when he was forced out but my point
is fox has always kind of been there to
be uh CNN light in a sense right that's
why no one cares about Hannity right I
mean like people watch him obviously but
when it came to the Dominion lawsuit
Tucker Carlson's the one that gets the
boot Tucker Carlson is the one that is
getting silenced the other personalities
they have are acceptable mainstream uh
harmless conservative values yeah like
the establishment isn't that horrified
if you talk about cutting top marginal
tax rates by five percent or you know
whatever your policy is being proposed
by The Establishment Republicans and
cutting tax rates is not a bad thing to
do I'm in favor of that but you're not
going to get in as much trouble for
saying that as you are going to for
pointing out the transgender and lgbtq
agenda or the fact that January 6th was
almost certainly fed selection and there
was Federal involvement the kinds of
things Tucker was saying which got him
pushed off of the network now uh I
wonder why it is
and we want to take a shot at it uh how
come we're only learning about it now
I mean people like Fox News have been
been working for a long time this is not
new stuff they're doing they've been
doing it for some time so how come only
now are we learning about it well I
think a lot of people who work at the
Fox network are not conservative right
and so they wouldn't feel a need to blow
the whistle on this
I mean this is not just not conservative
yeah no I hear you but far left sexual
agreed but that's what the left has been
completely taken over by right I mean
these are these are people who the
people who work at foxes are people who
work in media who have a New York but
you know what I'm not saying that's
everyone at Fox but maybe the argument
that they're default liberals who don't
pay attention and don't care but if
that's the case then these people
sitting by well this is the kind of
stuff that gets pushed to them by Fox I
mean at the very least they could come
and be like not Fox ain't conservative I
think this could also be a case where
the HR department is a different than
than the the the rest of the employees
right I mean I've worked a lot of
Corporations where the HR department is
sending out communiques and memos that
the employees are like what is this and
it's like ad Steve from HR and you just
throw it away I'm not saying that what's
happening is good
um but HR is is one of the first places
that that the left has infiltrated
that's true but it's a little bit more
than that Matt Walsh continues says not
all Fox employees are happy with this
propaganda that might be why last year
Fox experimented with a solution to
monitor employees commitment to Dei it's
an AI platform called escalera which
tracks employees commitment to The Cult
of Dei Fox leadership told employees to
sign up for escalera so that the AI
could help them engage in activities
that will deepen their understanding of
identity and explore more nuanced D and
I Concepts I I just feels like aliens
took over you know like there's like
aliens being like put the brain slug in
your brain and you're like I don't know
if I want to do that
you know what I mean yeah and it's even
creepier than that right I I won't get
into too much detail but we all know
that they're focusing on a different
organ and they're also focusing on
children yeah I think this very weird
pride month I will say it's sort of the
most memorable at least in my memory uh
and I think part of it is uh to your
question of why why are these documents
being released now I think people are
ready to start this debate in a way they
weren't in years past I think for so
long especially when the conversation
was about uh gay marriage which it was
increasingly popular people were uh more
willing to have conversations about LGBT
well LGB issues in this place and then
when the tea was added and it got it
sort of became the most dominant letter
people became more resistant and I think
we're really seeing that play out now uh
and I I will honestly give Dylan
Mulvaney credit for this I mean Del
Mulvaney and Bud Light really kicked off
a national debate over what we are okay
with talking about and what we are okay
with our companies it could be the the
pride month to end all Pride months
which would be great it'd be beautiful
right this is the last one the last one
and and look how many corporations that
uh June 1 they changed their avatars to
the rainbow and June 2 it was one on
they were like all right you got your
day which is kind of what you do on St
Patrick's Day and what you do on you
know you get your little one day in the
Sun and and if this is the pride month
to end all Pride months I think a lot of
people would be absolutely thrilled with
that I think what I think people
thrilled I mean I I can't I I've said
this before on the show but I can't
imagine if you were part of this
community and suddenly your entire
identity is co-opted by this Fringe
movement that would just be terrible
this would be the worst and it is I'm
not surprised that a mega corporation
like Fox is is bowing down to Dei I mean
I kind of don't trust anyone and expect
that they all do this I think it's hard
for the American public because uh in
many ways there's no alternative to Fox
so to feel this level of betrayal is is
upsetting we we will get into this story
in a little bit later but I will also
mention that there was a tweet from an
organization called Music Fest in I
think it's Bethlehem Pennsylvania and
they were advertising a an all ages drag
show we I put out a tweet about it
saying like what's this all all about
Yingling they deleted the Tweet oh boy
the the you know internally in The
Newsroom they were like wow uh you know
I won't say the reporter's name but
they're like man it's been it's been a
rough month it's been a rough pride
month yeah like yeah maybe this is the
end of pride month because you you had
what major league baseball got rid of
their their pride logo within a day or
two Xbox did the same thing you got
Starbucks reeling from it uh or uh you
know say take the stuff down not denying
it you've got Target losing market share
Bud Light is now they've been knocked
down from the top spot I got to tell you
if you've got a marketing guy if you've
got a finance guy and they're walking
into their executive boardrooms and
they're going look we got to get our ESG
score this guy's probably going ESG
you're gonna lose 30 percent of your
market cap if you do this and they're
gonna be like yeah but we won't get
financing if we don't be like what do
you need financing for if you have no
customers and they're like okay
Washington posted a funny article today
about how uh
the the Bud Light deal was not
necessarily about Dylan Mulvaney but
because there's there's a movement
towards craft breweries anyway
like oh my gosh you guys are so freaking
ipas you guys are so good like wait wait
uh
but uh the ultimate Spin Doctors at the
Washington Post are probably off on this
course are skyrocketing yeah yeah it
said domestic beer is stagnating it's
like oh that's why Miller and Coors are
up 20 some odd percent yeah this is
their craft breweries
yes very small small little scrappy
startup Miller no one's buying it
anymore no you know I I really do think
we're at a point where most people know
the media is lying I gotta tell you man
I'm I'm fairly optimistic because
there are a lot of people I know
who are they consider themselves to be
moderate but for the longest time maybe
like a year ago or pre-covered really
but like during covet and slightly and
like into code but maybe a year ago
they'd be saying stuff like that it's
not true you guys are crazy now they're
going really yeah when I say things now
they're just like
we've seen enough like at a certain
point you just can't keep lying about
everything and expect people to believe
you them people don't pay attention
they'll hear it and they'll say that's
probably true but at a certain point
they're like I don't know man let me
check and then they do it starts slowly
with some people and then it starts
ramping up the more people that speak
out the more people are willing to speak
out and I think ultimately what it comes
down to is you know we hear that story
from Brandon strzok you got have you
heard a story before the walk away story
that uh he thought Donald Trump was
mocking a disabled reporter and so when
someone challenged him he was like okay
I'll debunk this and then he looks it up
and sure enough Trump was not and that
he said it physically hurt when he was
watching it like he didn't know what to
do
someone like that then comes out and
people say ah he's far right he's
grifting that works for a little while
but eventually you're in the city you're
in Miami you're in New York who knows
where right and you you have a party and
then everyone is basically in line with
the corporate establishment narrative
except for like one or two people and
then someone says something in past and
it's not true and then one person
finally stands nah I looked that up
that's not true check watch I'll show
you and they're like wait what really
eventually people who are looked up to
or maybe have higher Social Status start
rejecting it which creates a wave of
more and more people stepping out
rejecting it then you get that
inflection point Bud Light now everyone
can see that woke is shriveling and
failing and now I'm hearing stories of
non-political channels and like
YouTubers and influencers for no reason
just being like Oh I'm not woke by the
way like I'm not I'm gonna do any of
that yeah because they're worried about
not being popular and there are some
watershed moments that led to that I
mean the Dylan Mulvaney I agree with 100
was was in this movement
um covid I think it was when Joe Rogan
said that CNN when they said on CNN that
Joe Rogan was taken horse dewormer and
that's when Joe Rogan was like are you
kidding me like like this and he it was
such a viral moment that everyone
realized oh wow CNN just lies about
these things and and so yeah that's when
the people in the crowd are starting to
realize they're not telling us all the
truth here are they and the more this
happens the better it is for society but
it's why platforms like this are
important that's why Joe Rogan's
important it's my alternative media is
important lying about Joe Rogan is a
bold move yeah he could he I mean he has
such a massive platform he can so easily
disprove it and there were other ways
that the media be clowned themselves
through the covid pandemic I think
I I was hoping to get away with just
throwing that one out but during coven
every time when the BLM riots were
happening when CNN published that
article and a number of other outlets
did as well publicizing the fact that
over a thousand health professionals
signed a letter saying that you
shouldn't shut down these protests
because of covid-19 after they'd spent
months telling you that you can't go to
church that you can't go to work that
you can't see dying relatives at the
hospital that you can't go to funerals
for loved ones that is when a lot of
people woke up and said oh it was all
nonsense it was all having my fingers
over here I'm seeing it you disagree I'm
waiting for Sheamus to complete his
point so I can jump in but I'm waving
frantically he's been waiting this whole
time they did not just say don't stop
BLM protests they actually said BLM
protest stopped the spread of coven
even better it's amazing they actually
let me just I'll try and follow this
pull this one out why are you pulling it
up you know what was the example of how
many people were losing loved ones and
then John Lewis there we go like John
Lewis gonna have you here we go yeah
look at this right June 30th 2020 black
lives matter protests may have slowed
overall spread of coronavirus in Denver
and other cities new study fines amazing
and at a certain point someone just
looks at that goes on there a minute you
can't just say it's a new study when
you're like my opinions
myself and I said it was fine imagine
being poor John in Gold like when you
had a when you were just or like like
like pathetic John Ingle like when you
had to write that and and just imagine
had to staring yourself from the mirror
and well you know or was compelled to
because he was so moved by the BLM stop
the spread they were all they were all
vaccinated at University of Colorado
Denver Professor there was one Professor
on it and the BLM staff when I'm a kid
and I'm watching the Batman animated
series you know I have a question how
does the Joker have henchmen right that
I'm watching The Dark Knight movie and
then the Joker burns his pile of money
and he's like tell your guys they work
for me now and he's like they won't work
for a freak and I'm like why would
anybody work for this guy he's burning
all the money
and then you realize why is this guy
writing this right because some people
are just henchmen they just don't have
independent thought they stand there
with drool pouring out of their mouths
and then their boss goes hey write a
story that claims Black lives matter
protest slowed covet slowed coven I was
like okay then he just writes it it's
like the dude may as well just be an AI
at this point well actually fair point
we can probably fire all these people
and replace them with AI so no
journalists and writers are very
important
lesson writers I'm not I'm talking about
timcast.com I'm talking about the
biggest threat the biggest industry
under threat right now is the propaganda
industry AI is going to replace all
these people how do we even know this
guy's real for all we know they started
doing AI articles over 10 years ago so
is that why they were always threatened
by the work by the term learn to code
because it quite literally was going to
replace them as journalists it was
offensive because they're all actually
an AI that does know how to code and
it's like I how dare you it was
offensive because you're only allowed to
talk to poor people that way basically
well yeah I don't know the working class
need to learn to code because the market
changes in the needs of the people shift
over time me no I just get to have this
job forever how about this now that all
these news organizations are collapsing
we can tell them all to learn to mine oh
mine cryptocurrency because that's the
future just my goal trying to save it
learn to form learn to farm yeah
make food
yeah well there you go that's the media
for you but uh let's jump to this next
story check this out we have this from
TV line Fox News issues cryptic
statement in Wake of calling Biden a
wannabe dictator will head's roll so we
all saw this apparently Fox News had a
panic attack because I just absolutely
love look we just talked about the
expose from Matt Walsh how foxes woke
and pushing woke indoctrination on their
employees an employee made a Chiron that
said wannabe dictator referring to Joe
Biden
Fox News panicked because they were now
being criticized by their peers in Media
because yes the people at Fox News care
more about the opinions of MSNBC and CNN
than about their own viewers
so by all means
uh well look I can only say this the
people who watch the show are currently
not watching Fox News yeah yeah how can
we get that message to the Fox News
viewer but they put out the statement
and it was very very vague to say the
Chiron was taken down immediately and
was addressed a spokesperson for Fox
News told CNN a statement Fox admitted
the message was inappropriate and that
it had taken steps to address the
situation internally but declined to
elaborate on specifics well apparently
they reprimanded the guy the producer
who then resigned I want to pull that
story but I do want to mention one thing
I do think that Chiron is inappropriate
well I'm sorry inadequate it didn't go
far enough that's what I meant to say it
didn't go far enough and I think I often
tell people this before the show like
hey make your arguments academic because
an academic statement and I mean I mean
that like a direct intelligent sounding
argument works so much better than a low
brow insult wannabe dictator applies
stuck across and put out a video at 6 30
today hitting the nail on the head with
the hammer about why Joe Biden is a
wannabe dictator but I think they could
have put up a more powerful and serious
Chiron that no one could have complained
about it could have said president it
could have said president speaks after
unprecedented move of arresting Maine
political rival
I mean that right there I felt I feel
would be substantially more powerful
than just saying wannabe dictator I
don't feel that actually conveyed a good
message yeah I agree I mean I I actually
think it's much more powerful as you
touched on when you have PBS you know
trying to quote unquote fact check Trump
as he's speaking in a much more academic
sounding way but Fox is out here
apologizing for this how many times has
CNN uh apologized for the the chirons
that they had underneath Donald Trump
right so I have a couple polls exactly
and fox shouldn't be either so I have
one here about angry Trump turning
briefing into propaganda session
um Trump uh trying to rewrite history on
coronavirus response uh here's another
one CNN Trump has no plans to claim any
personal responsibility for inciting
serial bomber thus of course implying in
the Chiron that he should be accepting
responsibility for inciting an actual
terrorist yeah but the diff differences
of the left and the right I mean the
left of the ones that lay down in
traffic over climate change the left are
the ones that go to the BLM protests and
burn down St John's Church so the left
does demand that that we respond to what
their philosophy is the right doesn't so
the right looks at CNN and they're like
that's ridiculous give me a break and
they go about their business so and to a
certain extent I'm gonna applaud the
left for being as tenacious as you could
possibly be because they're not going to
rest until Fox sends out the apology no
I got it shout out to all the antifa soy
boys yeah you know we want to criticize
them for being soy boys but those are
the guys that are screaming thumbing at
the mouth and going out and actually
engaging in real world activities
meanwhile Fox News which is supposed to
be the opposition
is actually completely on board with
everything they're saying and is only
secretly or is only on the surface
somewhat opposed to these things I got
to tell you right now spread the word
Fox News should be done
hands down the fact that this stuff is
now coming out the fact that there's two
big stories one
that they're indoctrinating their
employees this with this crazy cult
stuff and two they're bending the need
of CNN
CNN reaches out to Fox News and foxes
are like we we took it down oh you know
oh whoops what are the odds producers
hope we can still be friends what are
the answers producer was like I don't
want to work here anymore I'm going to
run this crazy Chiron and they're like
we took care of it internally because
he's like I'm quitting so it doesn't you
can't touch me I'm gonna write this
crazy thing and I'm leaving because
that's what it feels like to me like if
you're the person who wrote this you
knew that wannabe dictator would get you
in trouble right I mean at the very
least even if they weren't as you know
even if they weren't giving in to the
other side they know it's unprofessional
they know it's not blah blah blah I feel
like this producer was like I have one
last shot to do something before I leave
and this is it all right one last shot
that I would have come up with something
better like remember this he had to do
it on the fly yeah the New York Post guy
who who hacked their uh their their home
page and wrote all those articles like
that's the way you go out with it that's
true that's where you go out in a bank
that was flashing but maybe that one had
that guy had that was a while ago and I
remember watching that in real time
saying that game I was on my on the on
the uh New York Post app and I was like
that does not say what I should figure
out
he didn't say those things or actually
that's the way to go out on a bang well
Ben Shapiro's really pushing it this
time yeah for those that are familiar
with the story where uh somebody he was
working at New York Post right yeah and
he started just writing a whole bunch of
crazy fake articles and attack headlines
yeah just stuff you can't say on this
segment like just way over the top very
crazy stuff but that's not just quitting
your job that's that's saying like I no
longer want to work in media and I want
to go flip Burgers yeah yeah or become
I've won the lottery and I don't need
this job anymore you know I mean they're
similarly qualified right
media I'm not even saying this as a joke
or sarcastically Burger flippers have
more skills than journalists I think
that's probably true that's not a joke I
mean they're probably you could probably
argue that some of these reporters
writers journalists quote unquote at
these Outlets know how to use a Content
management system which is like okay
there's some skill involved but dude
learning how to log into a website ain't
no big deal now you want to talk about
somebody who's got to make a burger to
specifications come on you take the
average journalist and say make me a
medium rare burger and they're gonna
screw it up they're gonna they're not
gonna know what to put in it how much do
you put egg or you don't put egg I don't
even know how to make a burger like I'm
not gonna go and rag on a burger flipper
they know how to make food I don't
what's going to happen is they're gonna
end up flipping burgers and then when
you tell them they got the order wrong
they're gonna call you racist that's
basically the level at which they're
qualifying or they'll read it yeah no
problem
where else but this really does bug me
right there are people who flip Burgers
who get paid a lot of money to do it
more than many of these journalists
couple hundred thousand dollars a year
if you're like a top level dude who
makes the best burgers ever but
typically at that point you have like a
staff of chefs yeah but there are people
who work at Great diners they make real
burgers with real beef seasoned
perfectly and they get paid less than
these people yeah that is a travesty of
American capitalism I'm sorry
look bro it could be a McDonald's burger
they're bringing me more pleasure than
these people are right well they're
improving my life McDonald's is is like
a I I would give McDonald's like a c
minus you know it's like it's tasty it's
like you know you're drunk at night and
you're hanging with your friends at two
in the morning and you know if they're
open you can get a burger and whatever
it's like a turkey has these things
called wet hamburgers they're very much
like that you don't turn on CNN at two
in the morning you know when you're out
about buddies but I want to say this in
the utmost certainty a person who
produces cheeseburgers is benefiting
Society yeah unquestionably oh no doubt
somebody's got to go to work don't have
a lot of time they want to go with their
family and just grab a nice a burger and
fries I'm not talking about gorging
yourself I'm talking about a good
cheeseburger bacon maybe caramelized
onions what do what do these BuzzFeed
people produce listicles about
celebrities I used to like their quizzes
when they're stuck to quizzes
I think even a bad cheeseburger has more
to offer I I agree it's it's sustenance
but I will defend good writing so I
don't want to love all journalists
together like you can still read an
article in multiple outlets and a very
well written a good a good writer is is
rare and it's as good as a good burger
which is rare there's tons of lousy
burgers and then you've got a great one
there's tons of lousy articles but every
now and then you read well and you're
like that's a great writer and that has
value There's real journalism yes James
O'Keefe good right just good writers
though but like I'm talking about like
Prince I agree I print yeah the the
issue is
that that guy who wrote the there was
that article we were just reading um
Colorado Sun I think it was it said BLM
protests slowed the spread of covet like
that guy that's beautiful so imagine you
went to a diner and you said let me get
a cheeseburger and instead they brought
you out like a garden salad no no no no
no Garden salads have nutrients they
brought you out like scum from the
bottom of a table scraped off with a
paint scraper and put on a plate
something completely inedible that
smells terrible and they said that's
your food look I can't eat that and if
you did eat it you'd get sick it would
poison you these people produce the the
the uh they produce brain poison they
want you to eat things that poison your
brain that's what they make it is a
negative on society and then there's the
combination of the the gifted writer
who's also poison and I'm thinking of
the guy who wrote the profile piece on
Pete Buda judge
um oh that was amazing when he walked me
through an apps in the Cathedral of his
mind I thought holy cow like that's a
very beautiful poetic line but look at
this guy doing something
of his mind that I thought boy you're a
gifted writer and you're a total like
like shill at the same time that would
be like you going to a restaurant
ordering a cheeseburger and they bring
you out a steaming pile of feces and
then put whipped cream on it you're like
okay dude look you've you've put whipped
cream on it please but it's not it's not
sustenance it is a net negative so if
you look at the the holistic picture
here people flipping burgers they're
keeping us fed
sometimes people eat too many burgers
and they should probably switch to the
garden salad periodically but you know
at the same Diner where it got a little
line cook he's not getting paid as much
money as these these jerks in the
corporate press but they'll get you the
food you need and in the big picture the
people writing these articles that are
lying are poisoning this country yeah so
when people say the corporate press is
the enemy of the people when Michael
malice says stuff like that you look at
the Washington Post trying to lie about
the Bud Light stuff this is what they do
they lie about everything it is
remarkable the degree to which they lie
but people are waking up to it they're
starting to realize it's BS and I'm glad
to see it I also wonder if as dangerous
as the LIE is the Omission as when you
open up the Washington Post and they
just don't report the story it's
everyone saw it it happened yesterday
and they just ignore it that's like as
if it didn't matter and that I think is
just as dangerous well exactly so there
was a yougov poll in 2017 that showed 60
of Democrats believed that Russia
actually tampered with voting tallies in
the 2016 election now no one in the
media ever actually said that that
happened but they just repeatedly said
Trump Russia possible collusion
and it got to the point where this had
been repeated so many times your average
person just took for granted that it
happened
and then they went to the most extreme
version of what they were hearing
because of course no one in media was
willing to clarify that that wasn't what
was happening so even though they didn't
say anything openly dishonest at least
the ones who didn't know that there was
literally nothing to the allegations of
collusion they were convincing people to
believe something which was totally
factually inaccurate Let's uh let's
let's give some credit to this Fox News
employee we have the story from the
post-millennial Tucker Carlson reveals
producer who called Biden a wannabe
dictator was punished by Fox News and
resigned 24 hours later good for you
dude good for you standing up
just days it for Fox News displayed and
then apologized for a Chiron calling
Biden a wannabe dictator Tucker Carlson
slammed his former employer actually I I
think legally current I don't know is
Tucker saying he was fired
anyway they're going to mention the
Chiron wannabe dictator Fox's statement
saying the the words were up for less
than 30 seconds inside Fox the women who
run the network panicked Carlson said
they first scolded the producer who put
the banner on the screen and then less
than a day later he resigned he had been
at Fox for more than a decade he was
considered one of the most capable
people in the building he offered to
stay for the customary two weeks but Fox
told him to clear out his desk and leave
immediately the company then issued a
public apology for the Chiron that was
on the screen for less than 30 seconds
stating the Chiron was taken down
immediately adding that the issue was
addressed that was all true but it was
not enough to save Fox News from the
ensuing Scandal for a time and the rest
of the media Fox's assessment of Donald
Trump's arrest seemed to overshadow
Trump's arrest itself said Carlson
Carlson noted perennial MSNBC guest in
full-time Ukraine promoter Alexander
vinman who called for Fox News to be
banned uh called for Fox News be banned
on all military bases it was a really
great Point brought up by Tucker Carlson
because all of the lies from CNN and
MSNBC and uh where was he to say that
those networks should be banned from
military bases as well but uh I have an
idea
I'm gonna put uh I'm gonna I'm gonna
give a shout out to daily wire put that
on the spot a little bit we'll put Tim
cash on the spot a little bit
let's see how many of the Fox News
employees we can hire
the ones that don't want to work there
that don't agree with them that actually
care about American values reject the
lies and the manipulations and uh I say
the daily wire in fact I'm not really
putting on the spot I think the daily
wives start poaching Fox employees right
now just start hitting them up and uh
we'll do the same you know we'll uh if
you're if you're leaving Fox News you
don't want to work there anymore because
they're full of it because they're lying
we do not here at timcast have any kind
of Dei advocacy programs or requirements
or anything like that and uh
so yeah there you go opportunity awaits
yeah I think it's important one thing's
gonna be hiring some uh look I mean if
artists want to reach out to us who are
making uh animation that's decent and
who we could bring onto our team yeah
we're expanding so so uh hit me up if
you're like an artist if you're a
cartoonist who's qualified to animate
please send us a message and also if
you're someone who wants to support the
team that we have who are artists
creating non-wo content create a
conservative content please become a
member at freedomtunes.com it helps us
to keep everybody employed but I want to
mention here is that when Tucker was
first pushed out of fox I was cautiously
optimistic and I knew that he was going
to be fine but I was a little bit
worried because as I mentioned earlier
Fox tells conservatives what they're
allowed to believe and having somebody
like Tucker pushed out of the network
means that that Overton window shifts
back to the left a little bit and so I
was concerned by that but
I'm glad to see that fox which is
effectively controlled opposition is
starting to show its cracks and the
response to it is very decentralized if
you didn't like what the mainstream
media was saying for a very long time
Fox was your only option at least for
visual media if that's how you were
consuming news nowadays you have so many
different options it's wonderful there
are so many different podcasters and
journalists online who are delivering
information to the people from their own
angle whether they're just not far left
whether they're you know a more
traditional liberal a conservative
someone who's further to the right you
have a lot of different people who are
not all under one umbrella giving us
information that we never would have had
if it was just up to Fox I got an idea
here's what we at timcast will do we
will make mandatory employee training
yes and it will say things like have you
considered having a Fourth of July
barbecue and perhaps grilling and having
a nice non-bud light beer have you
considered reaching out to your friends
and explaining why America is the
greatest country on Earth perhaps you
should fly an American flag on your
property that's what we'll do I think we
need to train out the implicit
anti-white racist bias and everyone who
gets hired we need to have presentations
and stuff to to sort of brainwash them
yeah yeah
if you hire them from one of these
organizations you have to do it it's a
notoriously racist organization this is
against white people it got to deprogram
them it is something funny that I've
thought about there are people who
worked for uh Vice and BuzzFeed and I've
tweeted like I'm so sorry to hear you're
getting laid off you know we're hiring
and we're expanding and looking for
people so feel free to reach out they
never do of course but like what's gonna
happen when there's no game in town
anymore when you're when you're like a
buzzfeed Rider with no skills they're
going to be voting for communism because
the only thing they can do is write
nonsense listicles and other fake news
all they can do is write the fake
article they were told to write
but what are they going to do there's
going to be nowhere to work they're
going to go to Academia that's where
everyone who you know fails in politics
goes I just think yeah but like that's
the only place but then when the college
bubble bursts right because that's a
very real possibility especially with
money getting tighter if we see a
massive economic crash I mean some of
the first degrees
he'll keep that up forever of course I
know he'll be able to continue to do it
forever I'm not being entirely unserious
I mean even with this uh colorado-san
article that we're talking about with uh
this reference that journalist is
quoting a study where he's like and look
a professor at a university said it's
true I mean these relationships between
journalism and Academia could be really
powerful and strong could be a great way
to get new information out there it just
so often both sources are corrupt and
therefore release terrible information
that then the public is supposed to
consume without questioning well you
know totalitarian regimes always need
their academic sounding lackeys so in
that sense you'll always have the
university system as it stands for as
long as the regime continues to exist
however every single individual person
being pushed through it I don't know
that that's going to be sustainable in
fact no it's not going to be sustainable
it's a question of how many sacrifices
this system is going to force itself to
make in order to continue it because
it's a very valuable tool right not only
do you have 12 years of government
indoctrination but you throw another
four years on top of that where people
are being given an even more vicious and
depraved version of the same far left
ideology that kids are set up to believe
in their first 12 years of education
that you end up with a very high flute
and academic sounding surfs so it's it's
a valuable venture to them but I really
think at some point they're just not
going to be able to afford it and then
there will be less professorships
available money is not a real thing
though I mean we just give huge loans
from I mean what is it 94 of all student
loans are from the federal government
that we then give to people to go into
debt to then say we need more government
to solve the problems I am now facing
because I'm massively in debt and
theoretically overqualified for jobs I
don't really want anyways which is
causing me depression which is causing
me loneliness like we are pushing people
to a cliff I don't see me specifically I
don't think anyone in this room but the
system that is currently in place pushes
people towards a cliff that makes them
desperate and makes them compliant the
amount of government money also pushing
Academia that will hire all these folks
as government funds to do these studies
so that University of Colorado study
probably got a 50 000 Grant from the
Department of whatever at the Colorado
State House and and it just creates this
cycle I mean 1.6 trillion dollars how to
go to something well no I was just going
to say the National Bureau of economic
research has said this before that
universities respond to the widened
availability of easy money and more
people being able to get loans by
raising their prices so the whole thing
does feed itself but at the same time
those dollars even though they can print
as many of them as they want they
represent real world resources and the
more the economy contracts the more
difficult things get the harder it's
going to be for them to sustain it I
think we do want to see cities die I you
know you know I thought about this and
now I think no yeah you know we probably
should
because we were talking about it last
night in terms of how do you teach kids
hard work and I know you know this down
because you're a farmer and you've got
animals and I was telling the story
where we had someone I was showing
someone the property and we've got
insane fruit I've got mulberries there's
probably 700 000 mulberries just within
like a couple hundred feet it's Bonkers
you look at this tree it's just food for
days yeah you're not gonna you know
survive on just mulberries but there's
uh Allegheny Blackberry there's apples
there's pears there's walnuts we got paw
paws there is just food growing
everywhere that we want it to or not
and it's interesting that people who
grow up in cities don't experience that
I certainly do we had a a pair oh no we
had a plum and a Cherry Tree when I was
a little kid and so it's like oh yeah
food grows but people who live in these
cities are attached to these
corporations they don't know how to
survive without having a boss pay them
money and that was one of the it was
always something really crazy to me
when people would say stuff like I need
a job and I'd be like no I need to make
money like where is this disconnect
there were people in my life would be
like I'm having a hard time because I
can't find a job and I said okay well
then go do a thing to make money but
they don't know how they don't they
don't these humans have never
experienced doing things on your own
they they lived in a house where the
food was just there they got old enough
they got a job the boss gave them the
money for in exchange for the work and
then when they lost that job said well
now what
for me my mentality was always you don't
need a job you need to convince someone
legally to exchange the money in their
hands for to your hands like you need
someone to have money in their hand to
go like this and then you take and say
thank you now figure out the safe legal
and moral way to make that happen and
that is you can trade stuff you can you
can perform I was I was busking in the
street you can do fundraising whatever
yeah but people in these cities have
become weird mechanized laborers
and their only their existence can all
it can they only exist to work for
someone else and that's in my opinion a
very serious problem and it's probably
if you look at the school system and how
it's just basically churning out workers
with this factory-like system where the
bell rings and everything I think that
may be it so you know what we've been
worse non-workers maybe now yeah maybe
we just need these cities to actually
fall apart so that people are forced to
re-align themselves with the world and
then actually start for one realizing if
you want food you have to work well I
think you can make the food there's a
huge problem I think with the younger uh
you young people with the younger
generation that the vast majority of
them for a living want to be
tick-tockers or YouTubers and not that
we would ever make fun of YouTubers
right who would do things on online I
think they're idiots I'm a journalist
but you have to admit like what you are
all bringing to the table is a certain
skill set that people say it's worth my
two hours right now because the value I
am getting for that is greater than and
it's not a a money exchange although
there are members of timcast.com
um but it is a Time exchange
um I don't think a lot of young people
see well what is the skill I am bringing
it's like well I want the fame I want
the notoriety I want the I want the
clicks yeah I want the viewers but what
is the skill you are bringing to the
platform whether it's tick tock whether
it's YouTube whatever it is or are you
are you showing people how to lift
weights are you giving people an idea of
how to think about the world it's like
no I just I just want to be a YouTuber
well I think that's the bad thing this
is where uh the effective Decades of
reality television are starting to set
in right people think I want the fame I
want the clicks on the notoriety I want
the attention and I want people to want
to know what I'm doing and saying and so
they exchange their privacy for uh
attention online I mean so many
influencers are actually just kind of
very serious open uh bloggers right
they'll tell you everything almost like
they'll show you the pictures of their
houses they'll show you the inside
outside their kids crying like and if
this is the way you want to live your
life I'm personally not comfortable
doing that but it does eventually for a
lot of people turn into their own
reality new TV show that then brands are
like oh we notice a lot of people like
you so we'll give you money and they're
able to cultivate a business off of
selling their privacy they don't sell a
skill they sell themselves well so this
idea of people becoming decadent and
lazy in cities dying eventually it's
certainly not a new one and it makes
sense right because the family is the
the building block of society and we see
families follow this trend when a family
becomes extremely wealthy usually within
a few Generations that wealth is gone
because you had a patriarch of the
family Who Rose up from nothing and was
able to develop a fortune for his
descendants and perhaps his sons build
upon that and they accumulate an even
greater Fortune but at some point they
end up having so much
to the point where they're not as
concerned with The Economic Consequences
of not putting in the hard work that
needs to be put in to maintain that kind
of a fortune they become lazy and
decadent they start spending that money
without sufficiently adding to it and
within two or three generations it's all
gone and I believe there are studies
that actually show within about three
generations most family fortunes
dissipate so we shouldn't be shocked to
see that happen on a larger scale with
these cities many of them were extremely
wealthy at one point but what happened
was the people became complacent they
became lazy they became more concerned
with consuming than producing and that's
why they're falling apart we are just
seeing the dissipation of
intergenerational wealth on a broad
scale
the Rockefeller Grand
great-grandchildren are the ones who are
probably my age maybe a little bit
younger older Etc
um so John D I think one of the greatest
Americans in the history of of our of
our nation right Standard Oil
um wealthiest man in the history of the
world by far way wealthier than Gates
and and and in proportion to the society
and to uh percent of GDP just just you
can't fathom the amount of money
um but his Grand his great-grandchildren
now are the one who are disowning him
climate change activists we we are
ashamed of our great grandfather his
legacy whatever money's left it's like
well you're going to give it up yeah I
was like you're so embarrassed give it
up like go get a job go flip Burgers
it's like well no like I want like what
great grandpa left to be like don't get
me wrong like I'm ashamed of it but I'm
not gonna go be like you people it
always makes me laugh and you know
there's I'm not the biggest fan of
Rockefeller but the reality is he saved
the whales right if we if we weren't
using oil people still would have been
hunting whales and they would have
hunted them to Extinction it's true he
saved the man any credit for it never
yeah the original Greenpeace activist
exactly but no but this is the thing he
saved it by producing something instead
of shouting at people yeah so then that
can't be celebrated now there's a
thought make things yeah let's jump to
this story from the Daily Mail quote why
did you ask such a dumb question but in
snaps at reporter who asks him why he's
referred to as quote the big guy in FBI
Ukraine file it's not obviously because
I'm taking the money idiot this is the
quickest verbal moment while in office
yeah right the fancy never responded oh
man I've said this a million times
before but it was so it was so pathetic
the way the media was trying to position
this man as a kind caring adult right oh
Trump's the nasty one and Biden's nice
no no no Biden's nasty he's just not
funny like his kids
let me give you this this important
context I say the nickname was revealed
in an FBI memo that Republicans claim
proves Biden was at the center of a five
million dollar cash for influence
bribery game when he was vice president
if the memo shows that their informant
called Biden the big guy I mean that's
corroboration that is that is correct so
yeah I don't know how you get around
that and that will be the example I used
before of media Omission I I guess we
could pull up the sites right now but I
guarantee you on washingtonpost.com
there's not a mention to that on
newyorktimes.com there's just no mention
of this memo there's no mention of the
big guy they'll just ignore the story no
they're just going back and stealth
editing old articles about Biden being
like Biden who gets colloquially called
the big guy by everybody who's called
the big guy by his son
in high school you know no way yeah so
this is hilarious I think the campaign
was trying to get out in front of this
because there was a little picture book
published ostensibly for children about
Joe Biden and it mentioned his time in
high school and it says he was such a
good football player and he'd always
catch the ball so they called him hands
I'm like like that's not what that's not
what I call them you just know that they
were waiting for someone who went to
high school with him to be like we
called that guy hands he was weird
football man Biden besmirched the good
name of Corn Pop yeah Corn Pop was a
good dude who ran a bunch of good boys
that story about Corn Pop when Joe Biden
talks about how he's at the pool and the
kids are rubbing his legs corn pot was
probably like stop touching those kids
dude yeah no he wouldn't get off the
diving board I don't buy it I think he
was talking to those kids in Corn Pop
look at look at what he says about his
his first wife's death he he he says
that the guy who the truck driver was
drunk he wasn't remotely drunk he just
made up that story to make his wife more
sympathetic he was drinking his lunch
that day the truck driver's family sued
him wow for like a cease and desist
because they said like our dad was not a
drunk our dad wasn't drunk it was a
terrible car accident a lot of people
think maybe Mrs Biden was the drunk one
but I guess that will be a a autopsy
that it ever had but he has no problem
besmirching the good name of of
individuals if it helps his career so
he's not a good person he's
a terrible person if you're the kind of
person who doesn't mind being on camera
groping children they'll I really don't
think he's worried about life like what
is no just sniffing children in
public in front of ever like that's a
disgusting horrible thing to do and then
on top of that it's not of the
self-awareness to know like hey
everyone's watching me while I'm doing
this horrible disgusting Slinky thing
doesn't care he's like I can get away
with it yeah
no he's a very strong do you think he
sniffs his legs ever because of the hair
he's got a thing for it I imagine that
like when corn pop confronted Joe Biden
and was like you gotta stop touching
those kids man and then he grabs the
chain or whatever he had to change no no
so Bill Wright Mouse he was the only
white guy in the air and he did all the
pools and he brought me it worked showed
me all the mechanics where all the pool
of a filter is and uh he cut me off a
link to chain there was a chain that
went across the pool for the Deep edit
he cut him off the chain and he said you
tell Corn Pop That if you you may cut me
man but I'm gonna wrap this chain around
your head and if you don't tell him that
then don't come back and he was right so
Joe Biden these are the words of Joe
Biden's got a chain this is Joe Biden
you memorize that speech very well
that's the most famous president so it
speaks to me it's like the Gettysburg
Address so Corn Pop is confronting Joe
Biden who's abusing kids yeah and then
down the line people actually take this
story seriously that cone Pop's the bad
guy knowing the history of Joe Biden I
am convinced that Corn Pop was probably
a local kid who saw Joe Biden groping
kids and said yo we're gonna put a stop
at this him and his buddies and he's
like there's a couple of bad dude
there's bad boys it's like probably some
local kids who are like yo this
lifeguard keeps groping kids yeah make a
make a cartoon about what really
happened what really was a good dude I
got a bunch of good boys and one day
seriously though make up make a cartoon
of the truth
we did and then but take the statement
of him yeah but not not Joe Biden right
now that's not reliable the version
where he's like the kids are touching my
legs what actually happened yeah and the
guy's like you better knock it off Joe
you creepy hands hey hands stop groping
those kids they call me that cause of
football what are you talking about
catching footballs hands big guy Joe
Biden I was dying because here's the
thing no one has alleged that he was
called hands before and then they
published this little picture book that
says he was called Hans Biden in high
school I'm like that is not what they
call them handles not because he was
good at catching footballs
they're gonna write that as as a child
Hunter no they're gonna say uh uh Beau
Biden called him the big guy because
then they're gonna make it like don't
insult his yeah you can't question Beau
at all no who died in Iraq that's right
yeah tragically yeah one woman people
brought Hunter up to Joe they were
talking about his son he's like Bo is a
great kid dude if somebody started like
bringing up bad things I had done to my
father like how do you speak like how do
you speak to the fact that your son does
X Y and Z and then he started like
singing my brother's Praises I'd be like
oh my dad must be really embarrassed of
me yeah right well I think Joe Biden
knows if he if he brings a bow he can
deflect anything because people don't
want to comment on that right you think
they want to talk about it he says the
craziest anything do you remember when
his daughter's Diaries got leaked and
she just obviously is a very troubled
person and you have to wonder at what
point did she become very troubled uh as
she and her brother both abuse a lot of
draw drugs they have very serious issues
and they both grow up in the same
household so it's almost like there was
a bad influence in and around the
household they grew up in yeah like I
don't understand how we can think Joe
Biden is a good guy and just got really
unfortunate with these two super
privileged children who both are just
but nobody does no but nobody thinks
he's a good guy Democrats are lying
about everything that's true you know
it's like you you talk to people on the
right and they'll make fun of trump
they'll say stuff like what what's the
joke where uh Sheamus I think you made
it that Trump is a is like uh uh he's
like a street cred because he's got
three baby mamas oh yeah we did a
cartoon on that he has three baby mamas
and a criminal record like he the girls
love him now like people on the right
have no problem pointing out they know
these things about Trump there are
negative things about Trump but there
are reasons they like it people on the
left will defend literally anything
Biden does well no I'm sorry I'm sorry I
should clarify that many leftists won't
but they'll still vote for him that's I
I get that but there are liberals who in
the media the corporate neolibs are the
ones I'm actually talking about who no
matter what he does they will lie and
defend him
yeah well and that's the thing people
will talk about Donald Trump and they'll
say how could you Christians vote for
this man who's behaved in such an
unchristian way oh my goodness I forgot
all of these wonderful opportunities I
have to vote for good Christians in
politics who do good Christian things
all the time it's completely nonsense
like when when was there ever this
option of wonderful virtuous people to
pick from in American politics in my
lifetime there was it you know what's
great about Donald Trump he doesn't hate
me he doesn't hate me like every other
person I've had the opportunity to vote
for does so you voted for people who
hate you no I I didn't vote for those
people because the first presidential
election I was old enough to vote in was
Trump first Hillary oh yeah
we don't have to talk about it no yeah
well this was also back when I was uh
still living in Cook County right so my
vote wasn't going to do anything but I
still voted for him
yeah you weren't with her believe it or
not I I did think it was her turn but I
thought this is Cook County my vote
won't mean anything
as a joke he voted for Trump I voted for
him wholeheartedly I was still living in
DC in 16 and we joked when the results
came in and Trump had like 4 500 and
something votes and we were like I bet
you we know all of those people
are like six degrees of separation like
we could probably figure out who they
are we're all at the same time
it's us guys so so uh what do you think
is gonna happen you think uh
you think Trump gets the nomination goes
goes up against Biden then wins or what
oh yeah I'll let you make the prediction
yeah well I think Biden has a I don't I
won't say if it's that cut and dry
um I don't think it's going to be 20 20
all over again because Biden has a
record to run on
um ultimately if you want to think I'm a
conspiracy theorist Lunas lunatic which
I am
um they have to find the covet variant
by 2024. but it can't be covered bird
flu whatever it is they have to go back
to mail-in ballots they have to go back
to bird flu they have to they they can't
win any other way or you don't think
it's gonna be a monkey pox surge it
could be wildfires it could be something
some pandemic has to happen that they
can control the balloting uh at the
local level because it's the only way
he's gonna something has to stop people
from being able to have fun yeah yeah
absolutely and there are just too many
and people like what about the Suburban
housewife the Suburban housewife is
tired of paying 475 for a dozen eggs and
she doesn't like Trump but she's really
really broke now look all that matters
is the Republicans political action
committees you name it whether it's
Trump or not they're going to run ads of
the trans activists bouncing their their
topless breasts at the White House yeah
and so and they're going to run those in
the suburbs non-stop they have to and
then Suburban moms are going to be like
oh no yep and and and calling those
parents domestic terrorists yeah you
know that's that's the type of stuff so
if you're going to go after our kids
then then we're going to use our kids to
go after you
um well that's that's the winner let's
talk about this story uh from the post
millennial Yingling sponsors PA Pride
drag show for families quote need your
drag fix before our iconic Music Fest
drag show well the Queens return to
Music Fest Cafe Press by Yingling on
June 30th so here's what I want to
clarify they deleted this tweet that's
that's very interesting the venue's
title
the venue is called Music Fest Cafe
presented by Yingling that's the name of
the venue so if you were to host a
birthday party there you'd say hey show
up to Music Fest Cafe presented by
Yingling that's where the party is
however a lot of people are trying to
use it as an absolute defensive Yingling
I don't think it's an absolute defense
but I think it is a decent one
they say the festival's Facebook page
wrote on June 12th uh this this post was
well on Twitter they deleted it on
Twitter we uh timcast news team reached
out they confirmed it is an all ages
drag show you can bring your kids and
they confirmed that uh it is still going
on and they don't know why the post was
removed
that being said I'm gonna say it I would
I would I'm not gonna be like oh
Yingling you know you got a boycott that
whatever I'm gonna be like you guys need
a statement on this one Yingling needs
to say if that is the case but look we
sponsored a venue and the venue does
what they do we didn't know they were
doing this we're not okay with that and
I think that's satisfactory as far as
I'm concerned but considering what's
been going on considering the Bud Light
effect in the backlash I think people
are probably already boycotting Yingling
over this I well I think it's possible
that Yingling might even be too afraid
to release a statement because they
might be thinking not enough people know
about this yet and if we release a
statement more of them will and it will
upset them and we don't want the Bud
Light effect to occur here well at least
about 45 000 right now know about it
yeah I mean look if they released a
statement saying we are sorry we sponsor
this you know if they J in being honest
like if they genuinely didn't know what
was happening then please say that I'll
go out you know I'll buy a uh I I can't
say I'll become a customer for the first
time because I already drink Yingling
but if they were intentionally
sponsoring this and they're going to
continue to sponsor the stuff then no I
will not buying if Yingling puts out a
statement and says not only did we not
sponsor this event but we are condemning
it if you stand against it I will go to
the local liquor store and buy all of
the Yingling they have right now give me
an excuse to buy more Yingling that's
what I'm asking you for but here's the
crazy thing the venue deleted the tweet
I wonder because so my understanding is
that the uh the the former head of
Yingling
very pro-trump and I think the family is
conservative pro-trump I think maybe the
Tweet came down because they got wind of
it because people were tagging them in
it being like what's this all about they
probably said hey take us off that we
didn't sponsor this event and so the
Tweet got removed apparently the people
are saying they edited the Facebook post
to remove sponsored by Yingling or
whatever but the event's still happening
and the venue is still a Yingling
sponsored venue so I still think it'd be
appropriate for them to issue a
statement but the point I was going to
make it's been a very bad pride month
for the pride people very good pride
month for me yeah I mean uh someone
mentioned super super chats that Xbox
did bring back their pride logo but
either way the fact that there's been
pushback at all the fact that worker the
workers in Starbucks says they were told
to take down decorations the fact that
Target said hide it in the back right
this stuff's being pushed back very very
heavily yeah it's been it's been a bad
month I think it's pretty incredible and
I think it tells American consumers the
power that they actually do have I think
so often we hear like uh it's happening
anyways or you don't want to like draw
attention to yourself or you know just
let them have the month or whatever and
this is the first time you're seeing the
tides turn with substantial evidence
that if you are uh irritated enough you
can in fact enact change well you know
what I think these people didn't
understand conservatives have always
been against this but mostly didn't care
moderate liberal types mostly just don't
care and they were like yeah you know
live in the live then they started going
after kids bringing in these books that
were gratuitous targeting children doing
these weird things and then they lost
the moderates the moderates now went to
the conservatives said please help me
get this smut out of my my child's
school and now the conservatives are
like yeah we're gonna get rid of all of
it yeah so now it's all getting pushed
out Target still sells the uh loves win
love wins doormats and stuff like that
and you want to say like actually that
is a a very long time ago we are well
past that being the issue the core issue
for this group and I think that's the
problem I think now that they've moved
on to pushing a genderless society full
of people who are torturing themselves
physically you know people don't want to
do that which is so funny because the
whole purpose of of being gay is your
gender but then where the but then there
are multiple genders it's like so then
which one is it right like yeah like are
you bisexual if there's only two
whatever Johns Hopkins for a second but
it took it back said lesbians are non
not not man yes oh you're a non-man at
the table the interesting thing about
that so this is like this week probably
everyone knows this but Johns Hopkins
had the definition for a second they say
they they disavow it now but uh a
lesbian is a non-man other non-men yes
but Johns Hopkins was the first the
Johns Hopkins I'm sorry it said a
non-man attracted to a non-man and so my
explanation was that means that magnets
are lesbians that's true
negative and positive North and South oh
okay yeah so so that means I got one for
you
all matter except for that which
comprises a man is a lesbian you know
why because that's true gravity yeah
because Mass attracts yeah the other
thing is that they left the term man in
the definition of gay so right it's just
lesbian that gets to be not gendered but
I was going to point out that Johns
Hopkins was the first uh Medical Center
in the U.S in 1966 to offer a change of
sex surgery like it is indicative of of
the direction they're drifting the only
reason that they stopped being at the
Forefront of gender ideology and gender
inter medical intervention was because
their chief of a psychology uh Paul
McHugh I think I'm getting his name
right uh was like no if people have a
gender issue we should help them but we
should only treat them for psychological
issues we should not offer them
physiological medical intervention and
that stopped it for 30 years he's the
one who campaigned to make sure these
surgeries weren't covered under Medicaid
and then eventually John talking
University was like no we really want to
make the money but that's my editorial
there but we are actually going to
braces and now they have one of the
leading gender I don't even know what
gender centers in the U.S like this was
something that has been happening for a
long time and I think the fact this this
school put out a definition got hit with
backlash said oh no we didn't mean that
we were just trying to be respectful of
all genders like they are telling you
the direction they're going in they have
been doing this for decades and yet
people
say like oh will they fix it so we'll
just let it go they they said they
didn't mean to erase all the lesbians so
you know it's fine a racist women in
general just all women
I mean I wrote about this during a
women's history
painting for uh the Equal Rights
Amendment he said she said repeatedly
that it wasn't about giving men and
women equality it's about erasing the
differences between men and women always
I just want everyone to hear that over
and over again like it's not about
helping women it's about deleting the
differences between genders which is
inherently destructive to society to the
family right that's the whole point they
don't want women they want men and women
to not know how to relate to one another
so that we'll have weak families because
if you have a weak family of a weak
society and then there's less of a
competing Authority structure for the
state or whatever perverse ideological
worldview they want to try to build Out
From the Ashes I don't want to live in a
genderless world and I'm very
comfortable with that I feel like
everyone should be against that I got
good news for you you never will they'll
try to push this stuff but ultimately
men or men and women are women even if
they don't live up to it well I mean
depending on what happens with the the
chemicals in our Foods birth control and
things like this seeping into our water
and maybe yeah well it's only the 15th
right is it June 15th 2017 today we
still have half the month to go let's
see what happens it's a wild ride no no
no no group has done more harm to gay
people than gay activists and you can
change that for lesbian trans
um you know I've been on the show a
bunch the audience knows I'm married to
a dude I don't really care about it no
one cares
um but we were talking the other night
like we were out in the field doing
something in the farm and Andrew by
better half who doesn't talk he's he's
pretty quiet uh farmer and he was like
remember 10 years ago when like no one
cared and he's like isn't it miserable
he was like I never he's like and we're
in our you know 40s he's like I've never
been more embarrassed to be gay than I
am right now wow and we live on a farm
in the middle of nowhere he's like it's
just miserable I'm like no I get you
it's like it is miserable he's like it's
just miserable I mean so no one has hurt
gay people more than gay activists and I
wouldn't put the trans movement as the
head of that but like honestly 10 years
ago it was so much easier like people
were like oh it's pride month and like
yeah for a second like yeah I don't care
like just just leave me alone but but I
don't think it's gay activist I think
it's leftists no well yeah but leftists
but in general well these are white
liberal women that's true they've used
us the way they've used BLM the black
people to push BLM the way they've used
Greta thundberg to push green issues
right it's just it's just miserable like
the best thing you could do to celebrate
pride month is just just shut up
leave it alone and I do agree with you
when they started bringing in the kids
it's when people like Andrew and I were
like we want nothing to do with this
yeah oh my God this is so freaking weird
and disgusting and perverted and now the
argument is becoming uh because we've
talked about it we've had we've had
people ask us do you think gay marriage
was the slippery slope to what they're
doing now but but I I disagree I'm like
when when we say like look like as you
mentioned you and your husband are off
doing your own thing and you're in a
farm in the middle of nowhere like I
don't care about that like you should
have the the rights and access and I've
I've I've had that position my whole
life when it came to the gay marriage
question just because something happens
and then another thing happens doesn't
mean that one is the fault of the other
right if we because that argument is
what they use to try and ban guns they
say oh when when more people have guns
you see more gun death and it's like
well okay sure but doesn't mean you
don't have the rights I'm not going to
take away someone's right to keep in
bear arms because some people do bad
things we ban those bad things get rid
of it we protect the good things I don't
know that it's it's gay marriage itself
I think it's the the
corporate the money around lobbying for
gay marriage like once that victory was
achieved we had to then take all of this
momentum that we had and turned it into
something else that we could sell and
make money off of and that benefited the
medical industry that pushes trans
ideology it benefits corporations like
Target that can sell you a rainbow
t-shirt and say like look I support you
and drag you back in I don't know that
it's like the legal issue but I do think
it's that uh all of the momentum that it
had had to go somewhere and someone was
like I have decided I'm going to steer
the ship in this crazy Direction and
they will follow I think if you're a
communist you're never satiated and so
they won quote unquote Victory I'm sure
you think it was a victory they won the
victory of gay marriage but like that
that wasn't it it was like what's next
and and it's the same with like the
green movement they never were like well
we got that so now we're done it's like
nope the same with the guns right we got
our loopholes not enough what's the next
one what's the next I think the left is
never satiated with they don't ever have
one Victory one Victory just leads to a
greater one and I agree with you I think
like Mary Edge like should people
whatever you can argue we can all
disagree and that's wonderful but no one
was like all right we're all done
everyone should close up shop
we're done it's like nowhere my view we
want the next thing I think guns is a
good analog to this I think we need more
constitutional carry across the board I
think people that use guns to kill the
innocent are evil and must be stopped so
my view is like
individuals have their rights but just
because you have access to something
doesn't mean it's your fault that
another person did something bad so if
there are groomers true and and abusers
trying to come into this space I'm not
going to blame two guys on a farm
running their own business well thank
you so it's not your fault what I would
say is I I actually I agree it's kind of
ironic because Tim says he doesn't
believe that the slippery slope started
with gay marriage and you were arguing
that it probably did I would actually
push it back before that and so what I
believe and I believe we've talked about
this when you were on the show uh before
but I'm Catholic I believe marriage is
between a man and a woman
I also believe that uh sex is supposed
to be unitive and pro-creative and when
we as a society decided that we were
going to accept the normalization of
artificial contraceptive methods we
basically
pushed this giant boulder down the hill
that was going to entirely interrupt and
subvert our understanding of human
sexuality and what it is so a lot of
people will say well this is the moment
where we started rolling down the
slippery slope or this is where we
should have stopped but my point is as
soon as that happened we had pushed the
Boulder and it wasn't going to stop
until we tried to turn it around and
reverse everything
I I don't I I just think
as I stated if there's a some basic
question of two people who want to mind
their own business I'm fine with it if
someone then tries to use that to then
do something evil we just say no you
know we recognize the difference but
they I will but then I guess you and I
we we just fundamentally disagree over
what's evil well and I certainly think
too the the when it came to the question
of gay marriage uh this is back what was
it proposition eight in California was
that was a big thing they voted against
the judges there was that famous line
from Jack Black where he was like
pretending to be Jesus on stage he says
your nation was built on separation of
church and state and I was confused
because I was like isn't that an
argument against gay marriage like if
marriage is a religious institution then
wouldn't you be in fact arguing for
civil unions and not marriage by saying
that I never understood but my position
was always was always was equal rights
or whatever but I do certainly
understand this does lead this this I I
do believe gay marriage led to the
question of polyamory and polygamy and
and things like that because then you
start asking more questions about out
what what defines the limitations of
whether or not someone has the right to
tax benefits and access and why would it
be limited to only one other person the
one I'm seeing a lot right now is uh
just good friend friends who get married
and they're like but I really like
they're my life partner like they like
them more than anyone else and they've
been in my life longer so why would I
get married to someone I'm dating versus
just like my best friend forever well uh
and that is another question about
unions right it would be what marriage
was in a post-marriage society
well I'm seeing this more and more all
the time like the entire reason that we
decided as a society collectively to
keep track at least at the government
level of who is getting married is
because we wanted to know who was
accountable for which children and also
who were making children that was the
point of it uh as as something that was
enshrined legislatively and so once you
move outside of that and this is why
I've mentioned I think this starts with
contraceptives because then you no
longer believe that marriage is about
having children about having a family
and so then it can basically become
about anything after that point you just
totally broadened the definition and I
think it's impossible after that to come
to a point and say like well this is
where we're gonna stop it you've already
opened that Pandora's Box like you no
longer have of that reason based
definition of what it's for
and you you either have to turn around
and do away with all of it or you're
just going to get more of it and this is
something that like straight people will
get mad at me for too because they'll
say well you're criticizing
contraceptives and I think one argument
that was made by a lot of gay rights
activists during uh the the 90s through
2010s when this was a much more hot
button issue was well conservatives
actually are not living and walking the
walk when it comes to this stuff because
they are using contraceptives and they
are getting divorced and that's actually
true that was one of the things that I
believe to open the door for all of this
boy Paul VI would be so happy right now
yeah I mean
really he's really very excited nice
nice job done yeah thank you he did yeah
he said basically years ago yeah very
prophetic yeah I wonder the main issue
for me was always about uh equal rights
and access not the definition of a
family I actually thought that if if
marriage is done in churches and in
temples and synagogues and its view
widely as a religious function in this
country then yeah then there's a
separation of church and state and for
the government to mandate a church
provide a ceremony or whatever would
seemingly be a violation of that yeah
this is christianization I was going to
say this is this is what we talk about
with the post-christian nation obviously
the the state realized the vital
importance of marriage that they adopted
it and it became a state thing the
question is should it still be a state
thing and I would argue it should
there's a value to the family there's a
value to to to moms and dads and keeping
track of children and it used to be for
the purity of the bloodline also that we
weren't making sure that you were
marrying your first cousin or
etc etc that was a very important role
of it but the the state has adopted
principles of religion because it was
valuable for society it's very much even
from the secular point of view someone
like Thomas Jefferson one of our great
Virginians as a proud Virginian now I'll
say you know wasn't himself particularly
Christian same with Ben Franklin but
realized the benefit in society yeah so
what happens when we become
post-christian is we throw away all of
that and we think Society is going to
continue as it is and it's not it's the
same as if we get rid of uh you know the
same as we're trying to adopt a
smartphone you know kids have been the
same for for five thousand ten thousand
a hundred and fifty thousand years and
now kids are totally different because
of this little device and we can't adopt
fast enough yeah I mean it hacks your it
kind of hacks your brain but I just want
to mention because you brought up Paul
the six but and I and you're right but I
just want to mention this usually when
I'll make these arguments I'll get hit
with you're arguing from a Catholic
perspective or making a religious
argument true that I'm Catholic but
you'll notice I did not invoke uh divine
revelation at all yeah that was you know
but but as but no no there's nothing
wrong with it without Catholic no no I
just want to mention this when I give
that explanation I'm speaking like from
the perspective of what makes sense for
a functioning Society I'm not I I at no
point said well the reason we have to do
it this way is because you know when two
baptized Christians get married and have
a sacramental marriage and they're
trying to get each other to Heaven I
believe all that's true but my argument
from this is from a perspective of why
is the government looking at this in the
first place yeah and there are plenty of
non-religious reasons for that and we
are not a healthy society and I love
that you said that I'm looking at this
for what is a healthy society and what I
find one of the more fascinating things
to do is go back and look at surveys
that have been done for 20 40 50 100
Years of of Happiness of depression
levels and every single survey shows
that we are a less happy we are more
depressed we are a we are not a healthy
Society right now do you agree with it
anyway do you agree with Sheamus's
interpretation of the purpose of family
absolutely how do you how do you
reconcile that you know that that's for
God is going to ask me that question
question one day because it doesn't make
any sense I'm a total contradiction but
I agree with them 100 I grew up Catholic
you know I realize what I am living
right now is not in accordance with with
my faith but I also understand that you
know I've for God how many years 20 30
years I tried to pretend I wasn't and
I'm like well that's that's it you know
what actually made me uh a couple things
made me come out and I was in my late
20s when it happened was um
uh one thing that made me come out was
how much I I uh didn't like gay people
because of their their vulgarity their
promiscuity Pride parades and I thought
I don't want to be anything like that so
I can be better so why you know like why
why are we allowing gay people to have
this awful reputation because they
brought it upon themselves quite frankly
that was one of the things that made me
come out nothing that made me come out
were a lot of the church scandals
um you know I grew up very devoutly
Catholic and I would see the number of
of things happen and everyone would sort
of absolve themselves and say well you
know that's unfortunate but we've moved
on and I thought well wait a second like
that Bishop is still going to be the
bishop and he knows all these things
happen in his diocese but I can't marry
Andrew because that's wrong I'm like oh
wait a second holding by the church like
how come that Bishop can keep his
diocese when all this is happening and
but I can't marry this so and that's a
knock on the church I admit it and God
will judge me for it I hope he's lenient
I pray to him every day that he will be
but uh there are a couple things that
made me come out but but that doesn't
mean when it comes to society and the
role of the family I will change my
beliefs that's an interesting point
about the scandals in the church and the
inaction they've taken because perhaps
the corruption starts in the church and
their in their inaction on these
scandals yeah so there's definitely some
truth in that I would say um that you
know God is going to judge all of us at
the end of our lives but um of the
things you've discussed I don't think
the thing he's going to judge you for is
pointing out that there are bad people
in the church who did unbelievably
horrible things and I've spoken on this
in the past I think that anyone who is
involved with the abusive children or
covering up the abuse of children not
only has to be removed from their
position in the church but they need to
be prosecuted to the fullest possible
extent of the law I think it's an
absolute travesty what occurred it's
unbelievably horrific but that said
and that is an example of there being
really horrible people in the church
doing really horrible things but that
doesn't justify rejecting Church
teachings in other ways I love how the
many leftists will often bring up the
abuse at churches as some kind of gotcha
to people who are concerned about what's
happening in schools but it's like let
me ask you do you think that the parents
in these in these districts and these
diocese or whatever do you think that
they're like totally fine with what's
going on when they find out about it do
you think that they're just like no one
tell anybody what just happened or do
you think there's like Fury rage and
demands well I'll put it this way there
are many diocese that have rules that
say like no you know if you're a cleric
or you work from the church you cannot
be alone with a child and I have not
known a single priest who said this is
unfair you can't do this of course we
should be allowed to be alone with
Children And yet when Ron DeSantis in
Florida signs legislation which says you
can't have secret conversations with
children about sex that you then tell
them to withhold from their parents the
entire community in this country erupts
with crisis
yeah it's don't say hey right let's
let's jump to this story from Daily Mail
Gavin knew some ways possible criminal
prosecution of Ron DeSantis for
disgraceful migrant flights to
democrat-run Sanctuary cities I find
this story hilarious Gavin Newsom you
know what happened he saw Joe Biden
imprison his political opponent and
Newsome was like well I want to do that
so with Newsom entertaining the
possibility of a run for the presidency
and that I think he's even talked about
debating DeSantis it looks like they're
the B team and he's like my now is my
opportunity I'll do what Joe Biden did
get a bunch of press I think we're at
the point now where Democrats criminally
charging their political opponents is
favorable for them among their voter
base and they'll do it yeah it shows
tough it shows that they're strong it
shows that they're they're unafraid
um I think Gavin is just desperate for
media attention and like Joe Biden he
can't run on his record he has to run on
something else look at the state
California is the greatest state in the
nation as a New Yorker it's hard to say
that
um in terms of beauty and and topography
and resources and every song was about
California the OC was about California
and it's an absolute disaster right now
so he's got a back from the fact that
he's ruined the greatest state in the
country I got to read this it says Gavin
Newsom is working with the Texas Sheriff
to gather enough evidence to potentially
bring charges against Ron DeSantis or
flying migrants from the border to
democratic enclaves where are the
Republicans where are the conservatives
to do the exact same thing well it's
it's it's it's laughably sad they're
scared right yeah and you mentioned this
this looks good for Democrats you
mentioned they want to run on something
else you said it makes them look like
they're tough and that's very much the
case the only crime they're tough on is
thought crime you disagreed with our
position now we have to cast you we're
gonna we're gonna make an exam on you
the Republicans are like how dare you
we're gonna write a strongly worded
letter yeah yeah that's it that's the
last year about it you know California
is such a sad story because you're right
it's gorgeous California it's like it's
like the most gorgeous woman you've ever
met who's just completely out of her
mind right it's just you can understand
that when something or someone is that
beautiful maybe they can let themselves
slip in terms of Personality because
people are more willing to tolerate them
because of how beautiful they are I
think that's true of California it's
such a gorgeous place that they were
able to get away with treating people
there so poorly for so long but
eventually everyone's Gonna Leave You
well anusa made some big promises right
didn't he say he was gonna like end all
homeless homelessness by what 2030 or
something like we are coming up on his
on he's got a couple years all right
he's gonna put him on a bus yeah
Senator Martha's Vineyard
I think it's hysterical though that
these Democrats who said like we're a
sanctuary State all are welcome it's
like okay we'll send them there and it's
like whoa whoa whoa we didn't really
mean that all are welcome so it's like
are you a sanctuary state do you embrace
it or not yeah I think it's great and I
think that the states like Florida
Governors like DeSantis saying you want
to be the sanctuary State then I will
give you all of ours because we don't
want it in our state I I wish more would
do that quite frankly I mean if you're
going to be a sanctuary State then
embrace it completely well don't they
want the poor and tired huddled masses
exactly our foreign policy is based on a
lousy poem to raise money for the base
of the Statue of Liberty it's so
ridiculous and part of what I love about
uh the fact that these these uh you know
migrants were sent to Martha's Vineyard
and are sent to these blue states and
cities is they end up making all of our
arguments for us we just don't have the
resources you can't Shuffle people
around like this you can't put people
whoever you want it's cruel to do this
to them oh interesting is it after de
Santa said the Martha's Vineyard thing
who someone was going to bring human
trafficking charges against him right I
saw like was it Newsome I thought it was
uh
um the governor of Massachusetts but it
could be wrong oh yeah maybe but either
way I don't think you got charged with
human trafficking so I don't really know
what Gavin newsom's coming up with I
mean I I hope he runs for president I
feel like just let him die a political
death that would be super nice uh
because there's there has to be an end
to this idea that Gavin Newsom has has a
future he has destroyed California I
don't know who likes him I I don't think
California wants to keep him so what is
the game plan and the only way for him
to finally leave is to run for
presidency I'm convinced well yeah he's
he's seen himself as president
um he has very Dead behind the eyes look
like when you see him give an interview
Gavin Newsom does not look like like
without being too cruel he he gives off
a Vibe of true uh like Detachment like
like a lizard it's just a lizard does
not make you feel comfortable or calm
like he looking at Gavin Newsom is very
nerve-wracking have you seen the picture
of the lizard with the skin the Gavin
Newsom skin tape you know close close
pins to the back if not but that's
probably fairly accurate yeah funny meme
yeah I think this guy's evil I think
there's a lot of democrat Governors that
are just pure evil the killing of uh the
elderly in these nursing homes with
covet and stuff like that Newsome was
issuing these mandates but then he got
caught not wearing a mask they they do
not practice what they preach and there
are people who just want to be sheep
yeah and and
for good or for ill one of the roles
that the state does have is the dejected
cast aside mentally ill who are who are
screaming on the street but now we call
it dignity by allowing them to stay on
the street and scream yeah and when you
look at cities like San Francisco or my
home city of New York where there are
literally thousands of people who are
completely and not just because they're
on drugs but they are truly mentally
psychotic who are screaming who are in
Terror where's the dignity in them
where's the Dignity of allowing this
poor guy who sees demons who is probably
truly schizophrenic and we leave him
there to defecate on himself to have
people throw things at him that that
there's no dignity in that and and
that's what these Governors do oh these
Mayors do on the daily basis and and
they call it they they try to take
praise for doing something for the
humanity it's just it's as vile as vile
gets and so I agree with you when you
say he's evil because what they're doing
is genuinely evil no I mean it's a very
good point when you see the Medieval Era
caricatured there's often the mad person
in a town who just kind of runs around
and as you described they're just
defecating and urinating and screaming
obscenities and nonsense and again
that's something you see in a caricature
of medieval life and it's also something
you see in California today they do
absolutely nothing for people who are
genuinely mentally ill because they
won't involuntarily commit them and you
know why it's because they don't see
human beings as human beings they don't
see those people as other persons who
need help they see them as something
useful for advancing their political
cause and they're less useful to them
when they're getting help they're more
useful to them when they're out on the
street screaming at strangers making
them feel horrified frightening children
do you think that there's any way for
these cities to win back trust the
American people I mean you can't really
take back the images of what these
cities have gone through or like the you
guys know what this huge homeless
encampment that Phoenix is trying to
clear out I mean how do you present
these cities to the American public and
say you should trust us with your
hometown I don't know where the breaking
point is right I I look at my home city
of New York and all my siblings and
their spouses who are all taking the
subway and they're all a little bit
petrified but you have to go to work and
then the Jordan Neely Daniel Penny event
happened I thought that would have been
a breaking point that enough New Yorkers
would have said you know what finally
someone came to our rescue finally this
guy is on the subway screaming I'm gonna
kill everyone on this car and some 24
year old was like I got your back guys
I'll take care of you
and that is another story and they're
trying and they're trying to put him in
jail for for 15 years and so I don't
know how much I guess the question is
which I hate to say how much worse does
things have to get before we hit rock
bottom I thought we hit rock bottom four
years ago and we haven't I don't know uh
I mean in all seriousness I do think
we're winning you know if you look at
the Bud Light effect no question yeah
the fact that Joe Biden the
administration had to condemn those
trans activists says a lot yeah they
know that it's bad for them in the long
run that's good but uh there's another
story in New York uh that just I just
retweeted it's a guy who a guy on the
train was threatening people and
reportedly according to a witness
punched this guy's girlfriend so this is
like well beyond just threatening
everybody and uh the guy in self-defense
stabbed him and they arrested him
the media just says arrested in the
killing of a man a homeless man in a
Subway well Tim no one should have to
fear for their life every time they go
punch an innocent woman in the face
yeah I had this very spicy tweet that
was about a woman who a guy tried to
rape her on the train and I was like
thank God no one tried to save her
because the rapist could have died yeah
and that's that's the reality I'm seeing
these leftists who are cheering on
Daniel Penny being indicted and I'm like
have you looked look at the news about
how many people were pushed in front of
trains how many women were attacked yeah
we need people to be willing to defend
each other and Jordan nearly
specifically had a record of attacking
people in and around the subway like
this person in particular it wasn't like
this was a one-time tragic mental break
that he was suffering and you know
whatever like this person had a specific
violent criminal history tied to the
subway yeah this is a terrible situation
but not unprecedented and those those 40
different times that he was arrested
none of them made headlines right when
he tried kidnapping a
child's face didn't make headlines nope
and then the media Ian pointed this out
as great the report of Penny's
indictment shows him in cuffs being led
by the cops and then it shows Neely with
this glamorous shot of him as Michael
Jackson with the city lights incredible
Al Sharpton doing his eulogy because
there's a couple of bucks to be made
yeah just infuriating and what annoys me
about that when it comes to Urban policy
crime policy is like your prosecutors
like Alvin Bragg will say you know like
the 5 000 crimes committed there must be
5 000 criminals so we can't lock them
all up and it's like well no there
aren't there's one Jordan Neely who
committed 40 of those and there's
another who committed 50. the percentage
of criminals is very small and if you
just got that percentage of criminals
and put them in jail the crime would
disappear it's not like there are new
criminals it's just the same criminals
committing the same crimes over and over
again that aren't getting stopped it's
not it's not right rocket science yeah
do this well no that's that's absolutely
true and also there are crimes that we
don't prosecute anymore we had a guest
talking uh on this about the show uh
last week but when you look at theft I
mean I know that in California they're
saying if you steal less than 900 they
won't prosecute they're also less likely
to go for the uh go after these charges
in blue counties and States but as you
mentioned it's a small minority of
people who commit many different crimes
times remember they got Al Capone on tax
evasion right if you cannot go after
people for any crime and I mean actual
crimes that they commit I'm not talking
about trumped up charges I mean actual
crimes if you can't go after people for
crimes like theft then there are serial
criminals criminals who are uh
committing many violent Acts including
theft but they're only ever caught for
theft and you have two options either
you lock that person up and now they're
in jail for theft and they're not
committing other crimes or you let them
back out on the street to commit
whatever the crime they want yeah and
that's where you wonder if the the crime
if you're the leftist prosecutor now if
the crime that they're more excited
about is the thought crime and that is
the ones that they are going after those
are the ones whether it's on on social
media platforms whether it's uh you know
any threat to democracy those are the
crimes they're interested in and those
are the crimes they will go after hard
but the little petty crimes and it shows
the distance the disconnect between the
powerful and the regulars Alvin Bragg is
not taking the subway he may do a photo
album yep but his he's not worried about
his daughter getting on the subway
because if he has a daughter she's
probably got someone driving her to
school so so the more the comfortable we
are with other people dealing with the
consequences is is a huge problem well
and there's a kind of ideological brain
poisoning which occurs where a person
begins to think that their political
opponents are the root of all evil and
that the structure that they're trying
to tear down is the only reason people
do bad things so it ends up being the
case in their mind that the people who
commit the thought crimes are actually
responsible for all of the violent crime
that happens because their thought
crimes pull away from the ideologically
uh pure regime which could come to be
and solve the problems of crime and
violence and hunger if only these
troglodytes would get out of the way and
let it so just just so you know that
sound was me spinning the UFO which is
now spinning at a very high rate of
speed very nice yeah this is the take
the little blower here and then you just
you point it at it and then and that is
for the purpose of ah look how cool that
is it's spinning it is
what's up with that it's been very cool
we're gonna go to super chats if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
head over to timcast.com click join us
become a member one of the members only
uncensored show coming up at about 10
P.M Monday through Thursday we do these
members only on censored shows and we
even have you our members call in and
talk to us also go to timcast.com click
mobile app and you can download the
timcast official mobile app for all your
viewing pleasure for Android the
installation package is there it will
hopefully be up in the Play Store on
Apple and Android at some point but
we're waiting for approval it's dragging
out the app's been done for a while so
we said whatever we'll just put it up
all right I'm not your buddy guy says
Tucker's latest episode is spicy anyways
I hope those in Intel realize even if
you stop some bad guys becoming no
different than the nkvd isn't worth it
what is that what is nkvd
North yeah North Korean video Department
no isn't it the Russian I think it's the
Russian secret police during Soviet
times if I'm ready to rumble says it's
pronounced youngling as in a small
person child I have never heard anyone
call it youngling that is brand new
information and every bar I've ever gone
to they say we've got here you ask them
what they have and they'll be like we've
got cores we've got bud we've got
Heineken we've got Yingling we've got
and so that's why I say it maybe like
real yeah German maybe traditionally
yeah but here in America it's like uh
Celtic versus Celtics right yeah we have
our own ways to pronounce words and
we're Americans damn and we can
pronounce it how we want you're in our
country we're using whatever vowels we
see official citizen journalism from Jay
says the manager at my Starbucks told me
that she was instructed to keep holiday
decorations in moderation I wonder if
they're using semantics in regard to the
pride decorations oh so they can say we
didn't say take down the pride
decorations
Raymond g Stanley Jr says Tim folk
should lighten up on Biden he has a
speech impediment
so if we did a cartoon about this today
where we repeatedly
total gaslighting yeah yeah it's just a
speech you know he has that speech
impediment that makes you say poor kids
are just as talented as white kids you
know that one that's speech impediment
also participation trophies ruined the
West we saw it coming now it's a thing
to cry discrimination because fat people
can't can't fit
yep yep that's true I think airplanes
are where leftist ideology and physical
reality Clash one of the places because
you have people who are like I should be
allowed to fly even if I am morbidly
obese I'm sorry the plane can't lift you
yeah but I mean that's yeah I'm not
trying to be funny uh uh if certain
planes have weight restrictions and so
if if they have let's say 300 seats on a
plane and they put people who are twice
the average weight the plane would be
bogged down the fuel costs would be
exorbitant it's just not physically
possible so they're saying we should get
here's my solution to the problem I can
solve it right now
these overweight people are arguing that
it's discrimination to charge them more
for the same experience as another
person based on their weight and say
okay here's what we'll do
instead of selling seats we'll sell
seats in packages all seats will be in a
package of three
all the time
now if you're a single individual who
wants to fly on an American Airlines
flight from say New York to Los Angeles
and you only need one seat what do you
do no worries on the website there will
be a pod selection thing where you can
select a a seat and then ask someone
else to pitch in to buy the package
together
that's simple I have enough I have
another idea all right so I think
Airlines should charge by the pound
right because here's what I think if
someone weighs 300 pounds but they have
no carry-on yeah right and I weigh 170
and I have a 40 pound carry-on but it's
only supposed to be 30 pounds I could
charge an extra fifty dollars even
though I'm actually bringing less weight
on the plane than this person and I'm
taking up less space overall
economically it actually doesn't make
sense to just charge one seat per person
especially when there are people who are
so large they take up two seats I I like
the idea I I don't I don't have a lot of
luggage on a scale yeah yeah yeah weigh
me with my luggage charge me based on
that what you said was fascinating
though is how they're not talking about
the experience when you buy a plane
ticket you're not buying an experience
this isn't Disneyland buying your
service and so the the Wittgenstein
would love to be alive right now the way
we use language to manipulate manipulate
language for truth you're not buying an
experienced fatty you're buying you're
buying a service
this is getting getting so fat phobic do
you guys remember when Sydney Watson
tweeted about the fact that she was
trapped in between two uh rotunda
individuals on a flight and there was
there were articles written about this
and how horrible it was now look like
again I feel like I feel bad for people
who struggle with the word I really do
their people are big they're trying to
lose it I think that's got to be
horrible if you're in that situation
that really sucks and I I wish you the
best I wish you the best in your effort
to lose weight I really do uh but also
it sucks to be the skinny person who's
wedged in between two large people and
it does happen and it's not fair to put
people in that situation the woman said
it's not a choice she said being
overweight is not a choice it's not true
at some point you kind of break your
body at some and it at some point you
actually can become so large that you
break your body and it becomes much more
difficult to lose the weight but I think
a lot of people just don't try and then
they say oh it's impossible I think a
lot of people don't know to be
completely honest being six foot three
in economy is is not a choice right
right and when the person in front of
you reclines and it's like well this is
what about my experience right I mean I
I can't lose any any height I can lose
height harder than it is for you to lose
my extra leg room they could buy an
extra seat that's so true that's a great
point I do buy extra leg room exactly
for that reason because I'm six three so
if you buy extra side rooms have you
seen the new proposed staggered seating
for for uh air travel it was horrifying
instead of just two seats front and
front and back they stack one up a foot
so it's slightly above because yeah so
the lower one looks I would I would go
claustrophobic yes so there's after this
explain to me so okay you have two seats
like this right okay once a year and
once here when they recline you know
it's like that now what they're doing is
they're lifting it up and moving it back
so your your legs go underneath their
seat so and then you have a TV or
whatever it is in front of you you can
fit a lot more if you see them so you're
lifting up and moving it back so now
you've then you've got one down then
you've got one up and so there was this
hilarious article and it said there is a
physical barrier between seats that if a
person passes gas the other passenger
won't notice
yeah I bet yeah yeah that's awful and
now I feel like livestock if you if you
had to go on a long flight like that
that's awful yeah that would be horrible
horrible video of Ryanair at one point
he was proposing uh taking out seats
that has the biggest standing room only
thing he's like you could get cheaper
flights and like in Europe that almost
makes sense right if your flight is 20
minutes okay maybe but then like this
situation for a long flight oh my gosh
he said the flight London to Paris which
you said we do like 15 a day would be
standing room in the back and it would
be 20 and he's like you know how many
people for 20 bucks would get on a
standing room flight and I'm like you
know what yeah for an hour flight I I
probably would yeah
all right
it's threatening and screaming at people
you can't do anything because you're OMG
puppy says ingold says BLM protests
scared people into staying home and
that's why it slowed covet
because they were burning down buildings
what study are you citing tell me it's
University of Colorado I don't believe
you no it is he's referencing no I'm
saying like oh yeah but uh but people
were out by the thousands yeah you know
Russian colluder says Tim Music Fest
removed presented by Yingling from
Facebook post also fact-checking me in
that segment at 12 how dare you Greta
tunberg voice I graduated top of my
class at the Sheamus Coughlin School of
Journalism ah thank you I'm so glad I
remember yes of course I credited him I
like how Sheamus had this like Epiphany
he's like if journalists are just
reading things and then saying them
again and that makes them journalists
then I'm a journalist yeah so I bet I
put it in my Twitter bio I've been
telling people I'm a journalist I was
when I went on oan I was introduced that
way I look I'm a journalist that's just
how it is if you don't if you don't like
it then you have a problem with the
current Paradigm not me
it's like someone who calls himself
oh I should call myself an artist I'm an
artist
why are you giving up such an
interesting job pedal I'm a cartoonist
I'm an artist I own this business to be
a journalist when there's like 800 of
them there are so many journalists are
holy literally they're special any
random iPhone down the street in DC and
hit a hundred journals and that would be
a hate crime and I would tell you not to
do that and then you'd end up how many
cartoonists are there like it's so much
more interesting that you can be like
I'm shoes College I make my living
making cartoons like that's amazing
here's the thing I think you're not
seeing this because you're not a
sophisticated journalist like me there
is no position in society higher to
occupy than someone who reads things
other people wrote and then restates
them in a morally indignant way while
calling people racist well I do that but
that without calling people racist
without calling people racist I call
them commies but you've actually done
journalism in the field like you've gone
to other countries and followed stories
you've been in war zones to be fair
if you are somebody who reads what other
people writes and then have to correct
them on their errors yeah that is the
modern journalist and uh that's what
they claim they're doing but they're
actually lying fact check so so the real
fact Checker too but to be fair the real
issue isn't are you someone who reads
things and then resets them it's in what
way
if uh for us here uh at timcast for
instance particularly me where we do
this show we have conversations about
stuff we will read an article and then
we'll break it down add context to it
and opponent like any other opinion show
so I don't say that this here I'm doing
journalism I do sometimes I do make
phone calls I do get comments and
everything but uh and I say it's
punditry it's it's commentary it's a
talk show
what the these these quote-unquote
journalists are doing is they're reading
things and then figuring out how to Omit
rearrange and shift words to to trick
people into believing the wrong thing
while legally getting away with it
they're editors like when they said the
right wing rage Target had to evacuate a
bunch of source over bomb threats to
imply that right Wingers were sending
bomb threats when it was in fact a LGBT
Ally saying it that's what the
journalists do so when you say you're a
journalist Sheamus it's actually oof
listen I don't care what you guys say
I'm a journalist that makes me cool I'm
turning it around I'm buying low and I'm
selling High I'm gonna make journalism
cool again you are and then it's gonna
be worth something yeah what's wrong
with that Hannah
that was a hate Chris I said Hannah and
then I said Clara we got it we got a
good one here Papa Romano says Daniel
Turner had one of the best lines in IRL
history oh boy the Biden family is like
the Kennedys without the money or the
class
thanks buddy I appreciate that without
the money
so true
Marion Holtzman says the main stain
media is dead finally thank you
president Trump for showing the normies
America is awake thank goodness
yeah I think a lot of people because
there was there was a period where like
I have some friends you know back home
in Chicago whatever and they have
friends who are like liberal and would
complain and say stuff and I'd be
talking to them and be like yeah but you
know you know when I tell that to so and
so they say this that or otherwise now I
go to them and I'm like oh I got one for
you tell them this oh No actually
they're based and I'm like wait what
yeah now they're on board like they're
at this point I say to them they go oh
wow they no longer disagree they're just
like done with it and I'm like okay well
you know well now I'm not having fun you
know what I mean like the fun was to be
like oh I got something to prove it here
let's let's do it but now we've won that
ground and I'm like okay well I just got
back I got back to work get back to work
I guess you know it's tough but you take
your victories where you can get them
you know what I mean
it's a tough life being right
Anthony Brownlee says has anyone seen
the video just put out by a Russian
hacker group saying Europe has 48 hours
to prepare because they're going to
destroy the economy oh boy I don't
believe it that's rude of them how many
hours ago did they put it out yeah it
was like a day ago was it a Russian
social media site what was who was the
guy who was on them
yeah
it was like Russian hackers is there
activists basically yeah I mean they
were gonna do in 48 hours but it's been
more than 48 hours so like
well I didn't say which 48 Hours he
didn't say when it was starting good
point yeah they didn't say this is it
business hours yeah because then it ends
at five they've got a couple days that's
right good point 48 business hours
the topping show says hi Tim fellow
Refugee from Illinois any advice for
overcoming censorship I started a Daily
Show 89 days ago and I'm getting less
and less views it's mostly business but
I touched on trans issues the challenge
is
if you believe that the reason you're
not getting traffic is due to
persecution you may be falling into the
same trap as the left it could just be
that it's not content people want to
watch
or it could be that they're trying to
send to you before you get off the
ground
it's really hard to figure out which one
it is honestly I I I don't know
yeah yeah and I feel like everyone I
don't do YouTube other than when I'm on
here I guess but the people who are able
to make these algorithms Works say it
takes a lot of time you'd be really
consistent you have to figure it out
yeah so while Shadow Banning is a real
thing it may not be the exact reason you
just may not have found your Niche yet
it takes a long time right I've been
doing this for 10 years now and I
started Freedom tins when I was 19.
that's like when I started doing this
and it took five or six years before I
was ever able to make a living off of it
I mean you you really have to work at
this stuff for a long time to get it to
work and if if you're gonna say Well
they're Shadow Banning me
it's possible but is believing that
going to add to your life in any way no
like work harder make something better
make something more engaging and people
are going to be more likely to watch it
even if they are trying to Shadow ban
you this is actually a good idea from
Eric Miller he says Sheamus cartoon idea
wokey the clown gets fired from his job
at Bud Light no other company will hire
him so he takes a shot at Hollywood only
become homeless in San Francisco oh my
goodness that would just make me sad
because that's yeah just a depressing
story yeah you could do you could oh it
would be really cool if you do the whole
thing with like Sad Piano Montage Music
and it's like a kid growing up to get
his dream and Showbiz to be a clown he
gets hired and Bud Light checks his hand
and then it shows him like pride month
for the years that go by and then one
day the executive slams a newspaper on
the table showing Dylan mulvania and the
clowns like shaking and then because I'm
walking out going like you know holding
like an assigned always a sad climb I'm
just yeah now he's a sad club music I'm
just hearing the music in Toy Story when
they play the like Montage of like Jesse
like the girl being really into playing
with the Jessie yeah yeah
and then it just ends with him in uh San
Francisco as a homeless person trapped
under her bed like the doll and then
Gavin Newson Newson walks up and he's
like I'm here to help and then a bunch
of guys with it like guys in uniforms
like law enforcement with buses start
rounding up the homeless people and
that's the end of it setting them
somewhere else that yeah that's right
what a terrible cartoon you guys just
made this really sad like try to make
these
cartoons I didn't say I don't care about
cartoons I just said that journalist is
a more prestigious title
all right Sherman Panzer says last show
you talked about cowardice and bravery
and history shows many examples of it
like that of the Polish people in World
War II when faced against an unwinnable
fight against two super armies they
chose to fight despite the odds real
bravery yep you know what I learned I
learned something interesting I was
reading about this when I was growing up
there were a lot of Polish jokes you
ever hear a Polish joke about 500 000 of
them yes right right and I wondered why
that was I'm like where does it because
because like I know both people and like
have you met Luke I know why there are
polish jokes sure sure but like in all
seriousness though Luke is like an
extremely successful he's got like a big
YouTube channel and he's like some
people get lucky successful well but no
no but not seriousness
wondering why it was these jokes came to
be and it's actually rather horrifying
when the Nazis and the Soviets were
fighting over Poland the authoritarian
dictators executed their intellectuals
and their academic class and their heads
of state and Industry to to take control
of everything leaving only Farm Workers
and that's where they start creating
this Trope that Polish people were
stupid because they were brutally
murdered by Communists and Nazis no I'm
like wow that's that's that's actually
really horrifying and that's why in my
experience most Polish people I met have
been successful and intelligent because
of the ones that were able to escape
succeed and flee before the dictators
came and tried destroying their country
and even even though people like Luke
give them a bad name I actually think
they're older all right
I just want to make clear I think
they're unbelievably based I am a friend
of the full the Polish people I think
they're wonderful the every polish
priest I met has been extremely based
like they're they're one of the
countries in Europe that really has it
together still
that's a that's a brutal history of
jokes so it's like man that's not yeah
that's not funny
clown make another sad cartoon you need
to start a new series of miserably
suicidal cartoons I'm just gonna call it
the 20th century and just do every
horrible thing that happened in the 20th
century as a cartoon Bud's not bomb says
barisma whistleblower dad I do not
believe that's true uh take that with a
grain of salt I have not seen any strong
confirmation I've only heard rumors and
so that's why we haven't really I
haven't gone anywhere near the story I
don't know if you've heard anything kind
of clear everything I've seen is just I
no way to confirm it yeah it's like
someone said something somewhere I've
heard through someone that maybe it
seems like this and it's the bidens not
the clintons so odds are he's alive I
thought it was the FBI
he they look they're not going to take
him out but they will sniff his hair
you got to make that video
we have in Biden's Paradise he threatens
people me and my homies gonna be
sniffing your hair and then you make a
video where the Whistleblower is like if
anyone finds out I'm in serious trouble
and then it's like his name leaks and
he's like oh no then he's looking around
it looks over his shoulder he's like
walking to a store and then he hears a
noise like a shadow and then finally he
runs and he gets chased into an alley
there's a dead end and he turns around
and there's a silhouette walking right
up and he's like and then and then right
he goes no new here no no he goes he
goes he finally thinks he he's escaped
he's running from slams the door to his
house he gets in there oh
there's a shadow in the corner
walks out holding a bottle of L'Oreal I
knew you smell familiar
L'Oreal this flavor has the flavor and
name and like make model down no no no
flexover starts sniffing him he should
walk up to him and go like he should say
something like L'Oreal cucumber melon
patch 23.60. you think I wouldn't know
you watched it two days ago did it yeah
yeah today's social publication do you
think I'd miss that shampoo Man actually
it'd be funny if there was like a in
some way to incorporate Joe Biden's
enhanced sense of smell where he can
just instantly know the perfume the
shampoo and he's like the police are
trying to solve a murder mystery they're
bringing Joe Biden like a bloodhound
yeah
and then kamalar cops together
but when they find the kid then they're
like we did it We rescued the kid and
then the cops like we'll talk to each
other and be like well we couldn't have
done they shake their hands where's Joe
where's the kid
what they do is they um they give Joe
some hair clippings to find the kid you
know the deal I get to keep this
[Laughter]
is this a funny cartoon for you
this is a funny cartoon
all right all right where are we at
where are we at
um Curtis Reynolds says it's not aliens
that have taken over Tim it's demons
based same thing though am I right amen
I mean yeah that's the funny thing about
uh
science like secular interpretation we
talk about stimulism and how all of a
sudden you have these prominent secular
atheist type individuals who are pushing
rudimentary Christian beliefs or like
rudimentary you know judeo-christian
beliefs like a Creator created this
universe for some purpose and we're
living in their construct it's called
the simulation and I'm like I recommend
that if you believe that you go talk to
theologians who have been studying this
stuff
the thing is they are so desperate to
believe God is fake that they're willing
to believe the universe is fake but but
my point is at the same time if you
believe we live in a simulation then
what people of Faith would call the
demon could easily just correlate
perfectly with alien and if people are
like you know that you have the legend
of Gins and Genies or whatever like yes
large green men or whatever you want to
call it I don't know like Little Green
Men Tim lgm come on preferred term is
lgm people of little green is what
they're called that's the preferred term
we don't call them aliens it's offensive
men that they're undocumented they're
undocumented intelligent life
there's only
what about little green women there's no
they're only little green people people
of little green that's what I'm saying
because we don't know their their
genders we don't know their gender
identity JT says legal gay marriage
meant the government schools must teach
our kids why Billy has two dads and moms
I completely disagree no it doesn't
but no schools don't have to teach kids
about any of this stuff and they
shouldn't that's what I'm saying like
the book Heather has two mommies came
out way before gay marriage like people
were already wanting to enable you to
have these kind of conversations about
kids but this is the left the left
argument right uh parents should be able
to be like we don't want success for
success for our kids in schools end of
story we're done it like we don't want
them teaching about Mom and Dad and if a
kid asks another kid about some social
consequence that's between the child
peers to talk about amongst themselves
like the teachers should not be involved
in this if the parents don't want it to
be granted
you have the argument then what what
actually happens is the advocacy groups
demand the schools do it but that's a
big difference between they have to it's
just as you mentioned the the advocacy
groups are the ones driving this
so they don't have to and we saw that in
Florida
all right Sean Donahue says you guys
should try to get Dr Patrick more on the
show he would reframe your views on
climate change he is a smart fella I
worked for Greenpeace and one of the
reasons that I didn't want to work there
was because I started reading about him
and I learned about how he left the
organization and what he thought and
then I saw his arguments on nuclear
power and he's completely right and I'm
like if you look at nuclear power
there's substantially less death and
destruction than coal for instance but
for some reason they just will not allow
us they oppose it in every in every way
and I think it's because the climate
argument is more so about control than
it is about pollution I think pollution
is bad I think that we shouldn't pollute
as much I think that there's a lot of
cars on the road and we could be more
efficient 100 now I think that we could
have a better use of all of our fossil
fuels
but when they come out and they say no
nuclear power I'm like not you're lying
exactly that's how you know they don't
actually care right yeah
now I know you're lying because that's
clean energy you clearly just want to
neuter America's energy Independence if
if you claim to be an environmentalist
but you don't want nuclear power you are
quite transparently just calling for the
failure of America to provide energy for
its citizens that's all yeah Dalton says
I'm about to get out of the Navy after
almost a decade I was on LinkedIn and
saw the Navy pull their pride profile
picture down on June 2nd huge statement
from them and the people also looking
for a job guys LOL
we have in our Discord server
we have a bunch of job listings now so
and the reason we're doing it this way
is because we have when it comes to
contractors for a variety of things it's
been so difficult and Flaky so we're
like
we're probably gonna have a better go of
it with
people who actually care about what
we're building and want to be a part of
it then some dude we we found you know a
sign in a yard or a store or whatever or
word of mouth so we're going to start
digging into our emails and into our
um uh members for the work stuff the
idea was like we're wondering you know
I'm saying like it's taking way too long
to get all this stuff done
and the issue is that there are there
are normal things like material
purchases and permitting but it'll be
like we'll have a contractor who will
say yeah I can do it so it's Monday I'll
come back on Thursday with the plans
they come back on Thursday hear the
plans okay we approve the plans great we
can get started next week Thursday then
next week Thursday they say yeah we're a
little delayed it'll it'll be next
Tuesday the next Tuesday comes and they
say we're going to start bringing the
stuff in it should be here on Thursday
then Thursday comes and they're like yep
ship shipment's on its way it'll be here
probably tomorrow then Friday comes and
they're like now we're going to bring
the supplies in and we're like great we
can so we can start working next week
Thursday and I'm just like now we're two
months in just no one started nothing's
happened you know exactly what I'm
talking about yep yeah it's very
frustrating so if you can do it in-house
and bring in good talent talent's the
most valuable thing you have it's what
your earlier conversation of the young
kid who's needs a job what is the skill
that you are offering and if you have if
you have a skill that you can offer
you're invaluable I mean this this it's
we've been trying to get this building
up for like two years now it's it's
absolutely insane the sad thing is so
many will have a skill that is not
valuable yeah that's true I have a
masters in Congolese poetry it's like
that's great but it's not valuable yeah
please rewire my house with that yeah
all right everybody if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
this show with your friends go to
timcast.com download our mobile app for
your Android device and become a member
by clicking join us we're gonna have a
members only show live in a few minutes
you don't want to miss it those are a
lot of fun and we even we even have our
members call in and if you're a member
at the 25 per month level or you've been
a member at any level for at least six
months you can submit questions to call
into the show and we love taking your
calls so again timcast.com you can
follow the show at timcastirl you can
follow me on Instagram and Twitter and
if you want to see some super crazy
skate moves follow me on Instagram at
timcast Daily you want to shout anything
out I just want to thank you all for a
great conversation and for further proof
that the right is the most tolerant uh
class in in in in in in in the nation
um I would you would never be this level
of Tolerance if this was a group of
leftists with the the what I was saying
so I want to thank you for that Daniel
Turner power of the future
powerbeach.com if you love energy fossil
fuels issues or if you love sheep
Bristol Farm Virginia on Instagram uh
preeminent sheep farmers of Virginia
Bristol Farm Virginia yeah we got some
beautiful sheep right on they are
beautiful cheaper good people my name is
Seamus coglin I do cartoons I got a
channel called Freedom Tunes we just
released a video today called the trial
of Donald J Trump I think you guys are
going to enjoy it people are laughing at
it right now they seem to be eating it
up so go over there check it out I think
you'll love it hit that like button push
us up through the algorithm I love you
all have a wonderful day go to
freedomtoons.com become a member for ten
dollars a month and you'll get an extra
cartoon each week have a nice day do you
public speak for a living because yeah I
think if that was not clear that way
what did you not hear what I said Do you
wanna do you want to say it for me then
it's my turn say it for me aloud I
couldn't correct me I do know you can do
it better than me so why don't you say
what I said well that and cartoons I do
better than you now that you've moved on
to journalism oh no I'm just kidding uh
no shoes has cool stuff definitely check
that out I I am personally going to say
that you should go to timcast.com click
on the read tab see all the work from me
and all the other journalists you should
also follow at timcast news on Twitter
and Instagram it's the best if you want
to follow me personally you can follow
me on Instagram Hannah claire.beat and
you can follow me on Twitter at hcbr low
thank you so much I am serge.com I am
indeed pushing the buttons I don't talk
much on the show that sometimes just
don't feel like it but uh yeah I hope
you guys follow me on Twitter on
Instagram whatever you guys want to at
search.com spell it out we will see you
all over at timcast.com in a few minutes
thanks for hanging out